speaking to the 82nd airborne in poland
joe biden said when you're there you
will see men women standing in front of
a damn tank and everybody was like did
he just tell us troops that they will be
there in ukraine seeing this now some
people are saying it's out of context
that's not what he meant and i'm sure
that's
i hope that's not what he meant the
white house has issued a clarification
saying no no no no nobody's nobody's
going there in which case
i think we need a president who can
speak better because that's kind of a
scary thing to see a bunch of outlets
being like joe biden corrected no troops
are not going to be in ukraine so we'll
be talking about that we've got a bunch
of other stories and we'll talk a bit
about some cultural stuff we got this
story it's it's ben and jerry's in san
francisco this apparently this this one
like standalone store
splashed a crying homeless man with a
bucket of water that's that's what
they're accu being accused of and i
thought
man that really does exemplify san
francisco and a lot of what these
policies have resulted in so we'll talk
about that plus uh it's friday so we're
mostly chilling as we normally do and
joining us to hang out tonight is royce
white
do you want to introduce yourself thanks
for having me man i really appreciate it
it's an honor
my name is royce white i'm running for
congress in minnesota's fifth
congressional district against the the
anti-american candidate ilhan omar and
and her trusted team the squad the
progressive
the progressives
you think you're gonna do it uphill
battle i think all things are possible
through faith in god i'll say that right
on right on cool man well uh glad to
have you thanks for having me man we
also got brett dasavick of pop culture
crisis hanging out tonight how's it
going everybody yes my name is brett and
as a minnesota resident growing up uh i
pray that you manage to win please
thank you i appreciate that
hey everybody ian crossland over here
hanging out with a bunch of dice in
front of me as you probably already
guessed so many have a wonderful night
and i'll see you soon and i'm very
excited to have brett here as well for
sure because i enjoy going on pop
culture crisis with him but very excited
to hear what royce has to say i would
like to see illinois get defeated before
we get started my friends with an
awesome sponsor virtual shield head over
to surfinginternetsafe.com
and not only will you get 30 days free
you will get 50
off a lifetime discount virtual shield
is a virtual private network service
it's a basic layer of defense for you as
you're browsing the web their vpn
service is compatible with all devices
allows you to browse the web safely
secure securely and anonymously using
their global network of servers and
private ips it lets you browse the web
completely anonymously so the big name
isps and other third parties will not be
able to monitor and sell your internet
activity and browsing history when using
their vpn service your traffic is routed
through their secure and encrypted
servers this means that any restrictions
censorship or blocks on your internet
are bypassed you'll get complete you'll
get it for uh completely free for 30
days it's available for mac windows
iphone ipad android or chrome virtual
shield does all the work for you your
entire connection becomes secure private
and encrypted it routes your internet
through their advanced encrypted servers
across the globe to prevent your
internet service provider from being
able to track you
personal family and business plans are
available family plan includes 15
devices it will completely encrypt your
wi-fi connection blocking hackers and
everyone else from accessing any of your
data i always tell people we don't
expect people to break into our houses
but we still lock our doors in window so
virtual shield is an actual is an
excellent service if you are looking for
some kind of protection as you browse
the web so go to surfing internet safe
thank you virtual shield for sponsoring
the show and don't forget to head over
to timcast.com become a member to
support us all directly as a member
you're keeping all of our journalists
working and we're working on stories
every single day we're fact checking and
you'll also get access to our exclusive
segments from this show monday through
thursday at 8pm but also don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show right now take
that url posted wherever you can let
everybody know come watch this show
that's the best way to help let's read
this first story we have this one from
timcast.com
and i know some people are saying whoa
whoa whoa this headline is misleading or
let's let me read it for you biden tells
the 82nd airborne they're going to
ukraine contradicting previous promise
president joe biden told troops from the
82nd airborne division stationed in how
do you pronounce that uh raziao poland
probably probably absolutely wrong we
need where's jack when you need him or
luke uh that they would be going to
ukraine during his first state of the
union address the beginning of march
biden promised that he would not be
putting american boots on the ground
quote let me be clear our forces are not
engaged and will not engage in the
conflict with the russian forces in
ukraine however biden's words in poland
imply he has changed his mind quote
you're going to see when you're there
you're going to see women
young people standing in the middle in
front of a damn tank saying i'm not
leaving
so we have this from the daily mail
white house forced to correct by biden
after forced to correct biden after
hinted u.s troops would be sent into
ukraine in slip in speech to
paratroopers in poland
following biden's comments to the 82nd
airborne division in poland the white
house clarified saying the president has
been clear we are not sending us troops
to ukraine and there is no change in
that position all right i just got to
say there's a few scenarios here one
joe biden is a fumbling bumbling fool
and just was misspeaking saying you'll
see it when you're there maybe he meant
something else i honestly don't know
what could it mean to to tell a troop
they'll be seeing people standing in
front of a tank saying you know they're
not moving or whatever could joe biden
have accidentally said this
could he have accidentally leaked
advanced plans
is the white house lying
like is it a false like a false signal
we're going to be in the center is joe
biden nuts
all of i think all of it's on the table
it's all plausible all four all four of
your uh scenarios are plausible with
this with this guy
he just sounds so tired like all the
time like i people make a lot of
mistakes when they're tired and they're
you know their sleep patterns are drawn
out he's in poland right now so he's
traveling i could absolutely see
something like this being a slip up that
he's just not ready for public speaking
when he's that tired or that out of it
yeah like he's already got a
hypothetical setup in his mind so he's
like when this hypothetical comes that
is a hypothetical this will be the
situation yeah but the word when i mean
rumsfeld said this about the iraq war in
2002 before we were in iraq afghanistan
only he was like when we go into iraq
and it was like a signal like what do
you mean when what do you mean when
react's not on this isn't part of the
game right now yeah well it yeah well it
is part of the game for them
yeah for sure i would be mind blown if
the united states was not preparing to
send troops into ukraine in some way
absolutely or they don't already have
them there in some way i would be
shocked if joe biden wasn't taking mad
uppers of some sort yeah like this is
the kind of situation where you pay
privateers this is where privateers came
from you put people into ukraine you pay
them but they don't wear american
outfits they're just being paid by the
american government you know you know
you mentioned that uh biden seems tired
all the time
and watching these past several videos
he he is like when he was at the g7 when
he was talking about the new world order
and stuff he's just uh talking like this
you know i was talking to this guy in a
secure military he said
you know going to be a new world order
and i'm like
you know what man
they must have this dude on so many
pills to keep him moving
because tr for someone his age to be
traveling overseas to europe changing
sleep schedule working this much
i don't know how he does it because i
got to be honest i'm tired yeah you know
and i stay in this house most of the
time just working it's tough for me to
you know watching it
um i think we live in an age of double
crosses and triple crosses it's very
hard for me to tell whether or not he's
being puppeted or if he he's just in on
it and he's that sinister and i think
it's very hard to tell with a lot of
these global figures in positions like
his i have a hard time believing that
his is on purpose or that he's doing it
on purpose uh i actually believe that
drug i remember sticks hex and hammer
had a video when he got elected where
he's like i hope the ci he's like i
don't want him to be president but if he
is give him the good drugs
the cia i hope they give him the good
stuff to keep him awake so that people
don't think uh our president's falling
asleep
he's completely right you know make him
make make him work give him something so
all right let's see but let's say this
outside of whatever the whatever biden
is supposed to be saying and whatever he
meant
i don't know what do you think man do
you think they're going to send troops
you think nato will get involved you
think u.s troops are going to get
involved in ukraine go up against russia
it's hard to say i i think
ultimately
um
there is a four player jump ball
geopolitically you got the free people
of many nations around the world
you have your globalists you got russia
and china
and you know i think glenn beck laid
this out well i've written it before my
sub stack
china and russia won a a nationalist
dictatorship and the globalists won an
international dictatorship and i think
ukraine is is the the proxy ground for
the war between the globalists and and
and china and russia in many regards and
you know we're in the fog of war it's
hard to say what they'll do i would i
would lean towards
um they probably will you know intervene
in the ukraine in some way coming up
shortly when i think about like who's
who would win from a war between the
united states and russia would be china
i mean or be like the oligarchs like
klaus schwab but like when i think of
kolomoisky and how he created that tv
station to put um zelinski on a tv show
and then he made the political party to
put zolinski into power who's he who's
he connected with i think the people
that win ultimately in this are the
um central bank
financial cartels
um and when you when you push
you know nations
on a global stage
to this level of pressure and
desperation and
you know
it's all it's ultimately going to affect
the currency
yes it's also it's ultimately going to
potentially crash the currency which
would give them the opportunity to usher
in a new global digital currency which
which takes authoritarianism to an
entirely new height and i think that
they i don't think that they've been shy
about saying that that's their ambition
i think that we
as individual citizens who don't have
that type of sinister
mindset find it hard to believe that
they would sacrifice people in the
ukraine or anywhere else in order to
achieve that goal
now we got food shortages coming
yeah by fall because of fertilizer
because of uh exports in in uh ukraine i
think ukraine and hungary are are
pulling back on on wheat exports so
europe they're going to be going hungry
quite a bit devices are going to
skyrocket
was like a human-created mass starvation
the holdemore is that um
i wouldn't put it past an authoritarian
regime to murder hundreds of thousands
of people to get a an agenda across it's
it's been happening plenty of times in
the past i view it more like uh
or millions of billions i wouldn't even
put it past them to kill half the planet
to get an agenda across you got to watch
out for psychopathy
well i mean here's here's a point you
know first of all when you bring stuff
like that up the media just dismisses
you and calls you crazy i'm not saying
they're doing it i'm saying i wouldn't
put it past them the media will dismiss
you and call you crazy which is crazy
serial killers exist
many there have been many serial killers
who are very very smart and it's
terrifying how calculated they were
now imagine one of them just decides to
get in office
how hard is it i mean you know heaven
help us if a serial someone has a
psychotic individual serial killer
mindset gets a high ranking position in
the military also drugs make people
crazy i think hitler was on so many
drugs and yeah it was a big part of what
pushed him over the edge they were doing
meth
kept him going you know i see some of
these politicians who have been elected
let's say like an ilhan omar
and i've said in the beginning of this
campaign i don't know how much she's in
on it i don't know how much he's
initiated into these sort of global
level plans um but a lot of them are
useful drones for much more predatory
and and sophisticated uh predators i
mean you know players at the top level
and
yes
sociopathic psychopathic uh character
traits are all on the board i don't
think that anybody should dismiss them
in fact i think it's a it's a concerted
effort for the mainstream media to
dismiss these things out of hand because
they're in on it
oh yeah the mainstream media the fi the
five-headed hydra the new world order is
very clear to me you got big tech
you got the three industrial complexes
military media and medicine and you got
the central bank cartels and and they do
their best to make it seem like they're
not uh you know in on it together but
when you really take a step back and and
look at these things from a broader
scope they they all interplay and they
work together to you know to
quell what stories they need to and
promote others i'm going to pull this up
every time someone mentions the new
world order just so that i can say
here's what we're talking about this is
the council on foreign relations news
guard certified 100 out of 100 and they
say what is the liberal world order they
say world leaders created a series of
international organizations and
agreements to promote global cooperation
on issues including security trade
health and monetary policy the united
states has championed the system known
as the liberal world order for the past
75 years during this time the world has
enjoyed unprecedented unprecedented
peace and prosperity i i will dispute
that yeah right but uh but but this is
the idea this is the council on foreign
relations whether anybody you know they
say what is the new security council if
someone wants to come out and say the
new world order is a crackpot conspiracy
whatever it is you're talking about fine
sure when we're talking about big tech
and and the monetary fund look at this
don't they i think they actually
mentioned the international monetary
fund in here do they let me let me make
sure they're doing it right now
do they mention the world not even
they're so brazen about it there we go
look at this look at this evaluate the
success of the world bank and the
international monetary fund and
promoting trade development and economic
stability so we're talking about the
banking industry big tech and all that
stuff
just if you've got a problem with us
believing that uh take it up with the
council on foreign relations own website
which says it's real that's the only
thing i have to say is okay then if you
think that's a conspiracy theory those
crazy council on foreign relations
people putting those conspiracy theories
up they tricked us
oh man how dare they and when they mean
peace and prosperity they mean here not
where we're using it
yeah overseas for the first time we bomb
where we drop a bomb every eight seconds
it's it's peaceful here just not all the
other places where our influence is i
mean in the west it's peaceful in the
west for the most part i don't know i'm
pretty sure if you look at the southern
border with the cartels and uh look at
some of the most dangerous parts of
mexico are right on the southern border
of the united states so
yeah i'm not i'm not about to agree with
them like it's been unprecedented
precedented peace and prosperity you're
saying the whole premise is false it's a
non-starter i mean yeah yeah they might
be have something to it because there
was like how many hundreds of millions
were killed in the night in the
1900s like yeah world war one and two
was the most grotesque thing the humans
have ever done to themselves really it
was disgusting and we haven't done that
since we built this so that's the upside
and before in the 1800s it was probably
as gruesome not as gruesome because
machine guns changed a lot but
pretty damn gruesome in the 1800s too
like really really bad so this maybe i
mean i do think for the time that this
had a purpose but that the purpose has
passed i don't think that we need to go
to an autocratic global corporate
governance but i think that the liberal
economic order's over well i think it's
just real quick i think it's funny that
they're like what is the world trade
organization what is the world health
organization what is international law
but the new world order is a conspiracy
theory yeah like what
organizations exist i think what we're
looking at right here is
the fallout from um
a psychopathic man
named adolf hitler committing a a very
evil atrocity on a certain group of
people and and wanted to expand an
empire and have the german war machine
go and take over the world and then you
had a bunch of opportunists
whether out of fear or out of ambition
see the opportunity to use him as a
scapegoat to say the only way we could
stop this from happening is if we
consolidate power into international
governing bodies um and and and what's
interesting about the way they want to
do this is similar to how they
similar to what china has done if you
notice with china and how they've
reinitiated the re-education camps they
call them re-education camps because
they know and i'm not not to say that
the chinese the ccp hasn't killed
uyghurs or cultural minorities in these
camps what i'm saying is that they've
moved this sort of overton window of
what it means to be
um tyrannical and evil in a societal
framework so they'll say we're not
killing them like like they did it
like they did the jews we're just
putting them in re-education camps and
that sort of quails the visceral feeling
we have towards what happened to the
jews and i think the the the u.n and
these globalist international bodies are
doing a similar thing when they talk
about peace but then they're they're not
talking about the peace of of soul or
the peace of spirit uh they're talking
about physical conflict but the whole
scam is to make people very chaotic and
unpeaceful in their minds and bodies and
spirits yeah you can you can chain two
people up and they call it peaceful
because they can't fight but they're not
going to be happy that's not a good
piece for those people it's still a
degradation of humanity and dignity
right let's let's talk about your story
man how did you get involved in all this
where do you come from
well yep i'm i'll take you back to the
beginning because i i respect you a lot
and i told you that i think what you've
done man is is really and all the people
who have done what you've done creating
these conversations is an unquantifiable
contribution to society um
you know my story all started i'd say
came onto the public scene as a
basketball player at iowa state
university
um i i you know i was an all-american
high school athlete i came up through
the nike prep circuit as well
i went to the university of minnesota
which is in my hometown
but but i i transferred to iowa state i
had to sit a year back then you got you
got penalized a year for transferring
now they they have a sort of no penalty
rule but back then you got penalized a
year so i had a city year i didn't plan
to my junior year
um i had a good season and during this
season i
talked publicly about my struggles with
anxiety um and this was unique because a
lot of people in the public square
especially collegiate athletes but
really any public figures weren't
talking about mental health
as much it certainly wasn't the
mainstream sort of
buzz topic that has become now and many
could you could argue that i was sort of
the first stone in that avalanche uh and
and i'm and i'm actually kind of
disturbed and disappointed at how it
turned out and we'll talk about that
trajectory here a little bit but but
anyway
i started to talk about mental health
and i was playing well
uh and so it got a lot of traction
because the college sports writers were
going we never had a guy talk about
anxiety but we knew people had these
issues but also this guy is
leading his team in every major
statistical category points rebounds
blocks steals assists and i was the only
player in the country to do that and not
many players in the country do that in
any season it's kind of a statistical
anomaly
so there's this whole paradigm is
created now about
okay so what do we mean when we say
mental health then or mental health
issues or struggles or mental illness or
anxiety and so as the season went on i
continued to prove that i could compete
at the highest level against guys who
were projected to be first round picks
this went into the ncaa tournament
that's going on now my team iowa state's
playing tonight actually um in the sweet
16 but but in our tournament we played
the defending champs uconn
coached by jim calhoun at the time and i
had an incredible game against them they
had two high-level first-round picks
projected in that game and then we
played kentucky who had anthony davis on
the team at the time and six other
first-round draft picks projected and i
and i was the dominant player in that
game so then
you know the talk was okay this guy is
probably one of the most nba ready
players in his class
i declare for the draft and something
very very
strange you could say happened it
exploded the mental health conversation
because now the question was
how does the mba view mental illness do
they view it as a character flaw
or do they view it as
you know this
this integral piece of this
comprehensive health model right this
progressive view of health and mental
health as a spectrum where everybody has
a mental health right so that question
was posed by the the mainstream
establishment
and the answer was they did view it as a
character flaw and i push back on that
narrative immediately like as soon as
the story starts to drop sports
illustrated usa today royce is declaring
for the draft but he's a mystery pick
because of this whole anxiety snafu um
i'm going no no this ain't a character
flaw and the fact that it's even a
question proves that you guys don't
understand the real dynamic of what's
happening with this mental health crisis
long story short i get drafted
to the houston rockets 16th but i was
projected to have a top five talent mba
ready skill set
and
upon my arrival in the nba
i discovered by reading through my
collective bargaining agreement
our cba
that there wasn't a single mention of
mental health in the entire document
and i went to my team and i said listen
i want i want to be as good of a player
and as productive as i possibly can be
for you guys but i understand that
obviously by the language in this
document that the understanding around
mental health and the issue like the one
i deal with anxiety disorders is lacking
and i'm willing to have an open
conversation with you guys transparently
about what i deal with so that we could
have a better relationship and trying to
make me the most productive player i
could be
okay they said okay that's that's good
um okay well let's put it in writing i
said
let's figure this out how does this look
in writing oh we can't put any of this
in writing
i go why not you the the color of the
socks a guy has to wear in the game is
in writing is it really yeah oh it
absolutely is and the penalties and the
the real reason that i said we needed to
put it in writing because the cba
already had
a banned substance list that had
anti-anxiety medication on it whoa
okay so now i'm going
everybody's telling this narrative that
the pro sports world is uninitiated with
mental health as a topic but here's this
banned substance list
with
tons of
mental health related content in it so
somebody knew something about mental
health or know something and so i said
okay so let's say
for example
um
they basically said well look you can
take the xanax cause xanax was on the
banned substance you can take it don't
worry you got a doctor's prescription
and i go well wait a minute
why is it on the list
is it because if you take xanax for two
weeks
even as prescribed you can get addicted
and that is the truth about xanax it's
the most addictive drug there is in the
world and so they were right to have it
on the banned substance list but my
point was to say hey the reason i mostly
take xanax is because
i have i have a fear of flying or that
fear the flying exacerbates my anxiety
so how about we cut some of the xanax
out per year by allowing me to drive
from minnesota to say chicago
six hour drive
a little bit longer hike than a private
charter jet you know catered and all of
that but i was willing to take the hit
because i understood the dangers of
taking xanax for nine months
continuously and they said oh no we
can't do that
and so that's where the fight began
ultimately between me and the league and
and
and and i became this spokesperson on
mental health and what i was really
trying to say is like
it wasn't about me getting special
preferential treatment it was to say
that the mba
represents a global corporate community
which they do in fact it's the watering
hole for
every industry in in our society
and that there was something wrong with
the global corporate community and how
they viewed humanity and that mental
health wasn't about the dsm or diagnosis
it was to say that uh
mental health is another way to say the
human condition where mind body and
spirit converge and they wanted nothing
to do with that and they blackballed me
for that and they told me you're too
smart for your own good we agree with
you about mental health we agree it's an
epidemic we agree it's the crisis over
the hill but who are you to tell us to
change anything you don't have any
leverage uh so so you can either play
or you'll never become the spokesperson
that you could and we could make you be
on this issue and i've been fighting
that battle for the last 10 years did
you leave the league right away um i
gave them the ultimatum that we needed
to put a mental health policy in place
or that i wouldn't i wouldn't play
and then what happened
uh i was traded from houston to well
what happened was the houston rockets
owner at the time leslie alexander who
now sold the team to
fritida
who owns it now but but at the time
leslie alexander and his attorney
said to me hey
my daughter has anxiety his name is mr
goldberg he comes into a meeting first
of all they forced me to go
psychiatrists every day
and the psychiatrist told him don't do
that this isn't about him
needing psychiatric help he's telling
you guys that we need something in
writing that acknowledges mental health
as a core component of overall health
and i agree with them so then they got
pissed off at the psychiatrist
and so and and so they made me do that
every day or else i would be fined they
said so i went i said okay i'll go me
and this guy could chat it up actually
we'll start designing the policy which
we did
um and uh
basically they walked in there and after
two months of back and forth and them
telling me that you know for me to bust
to a game could be a salary cap
infringement and you know all of these
other weird kind of you know business
tactics intimidation tactics um they
finally just came in and said they had a
they sent an emissary right and it was
this attorney and he goes listen my
daughter has anxiety
she doesn't like to fly either but i
make her and she'll thank me for it
later she hates me now
um i agree with you this is a big issue
and if you agree to go to our d-league
which is now called the g-league minor
league affiliate
um in the offseason i'll help you put
this mental policy in place and i'll
make sure that the owners accept it when
the offseason came there was no talk of
that policy and i was traded to
philadelphia
um and philadelphia released me before
the season started even though the local
media there in philly thought that i was
a shoe-in to make that team
but sam hinkey who was who had been the
assistant gm under daryl mori who was an
interesting character in this whole uh
story arc um he was the understudy of
daryl mori so they basically did a trade
and dump
um and and and i was you know 21 years
old i was naive i had the inclination or
the instinct to block the trade um but i
was encouraged by the union that it
would be maybe advantageous for me
because philadelphia is in this east
coast coast corridor and there's a lot
of games that i would be able to drive
to uh throughout the season so you know
ultimately after the philadelphia thing
i just didn't get another shot i wrote
letters i you know i i had had medical
professionals mental health
professionals write letters and say this
mental health issue is real that the nba
is in a perfect position to
to
back up it's it's
it's promotion of caring about the
greater good um by by just putting in a
very simple doable mental health policy
and they just ignored me why do you
think they did that
at the time i thought it was because
they didn't there was something they
didn't know
i was arrogant i was mistaken i was
naive i i thought that i was going to be
able to bridge the gap through genuine
participation
of some type of some type of uh attitude
or perspective that they had gotten
wrong
but that wasn't the case
the entire corporatocracy knew that
psychological
uh that the the predatory
um predation let's say on on the human
psychology was the next iteration of the
war that they wanted to wage on the
common people i didn't i didn't get that
at the time that social media was around
the corner and the dopamine
uh the dopamine war was coming down the
her coming around the they knew it so
when i went to talk about mental health
and say hey hold on there's a mental
health there's a cultural mental health
renaissance and revolution that needs to
happen here right now
i'm sitting there thinking that they had
archaic views about mental health but i
was mistaken they were advanced around
the human psychology and they planned to
be predatory with it so they were
planning on like like they knew that it
was going to be weaponized like like
mental illness would be weaponized so
they didn't want to get involved let me
hit or something let me introduce real
quick there are companies when it comes
to mobile apps there was a viral i
covered this several years ago a company
says we can program your audience for
you so when you've got big companies
that are planning on making mobile apps
they're going to consultants saying how
can we make it so that people become
addicted to this
and then the company will analyze their
data and be like do these things and
people will become addicts yeah it's
digital addictions so and you can you
can
place that or stand that next to a 21
year old kid coming in saying hey why is
the alcohol cut off not at halftime
why is it okay why is it morally and
ethically okay for us to use taxpayer
money to build these arenas and then
build parking structures where we
basically incentivize people to drink
and drive with their kid or come to the
game and get drunk in front of their kid
or or even worse somebody else's kid and
yell this belligerent [ __ ] at the game
like
they were like and i'm sitting here
saying all this based on logic and
reason they're like we're about to go to
town on the working class through
psychological manipulation
i think it's it's it's simpler put to be
honest because i think you know the way
you describe it is
is what's happening but their attitude
is probably like how much did we just
pay this guy to make our mobile app that
that makes these these young kids
addicted to it 50 million 50 million we
can't have this guy screwing that up
yeah
right so they thought you were a threat
to the system that you're going to gain
too much power and influence in the
system twofold twofold
yes
but there's there's a canary in a coal
mine in this situation yes
in the immediate they're like uh this
kid is trying to change the status quo
and that's a danger but the mental
health topic as a topic in general
is the one topic that puts a mirror up
to the individual
so in spirit they didn't want to have
the mental health conversation because
they didn't want to have to look at
themselves
your story to me sounds like you know
you you thought that once you got in
people would be willing to engage with
you and you'd have a positive impact but
the reality is for for any for political
office even
you end up getting into a position where
there's a train coming at you and you're
trying to push against it that train is
going to keep coming
so you go in and good faith think you're
gonna have this impact and then we hear
it across the board from the presidency
to members of congress so like as soon
as you get in the machine controls you
yeah that
and then if you if you resist it enough
eventually the machine just shoves you
out of the way
and you know
as a young kid growing up i grew up in
the michael jordan era right in the twin
cities we're in chicago wgn we got all
the local bulls games
yeah we had wgn in twin cities so we got
to see all the home bulls games so i was
a basketball lover right and when you
when you grow up in a single mother
household
and she pays the rent with her tips
and and you go to the gym and you create
a relationship with the with the local
recreation center uh manager
and and he allows you to spend that
extra time in the gym all by yourself
just shooting just shooting playing
games with yourself to a hundred i'm the
bulls one night i'm the other team the
other night
you grow up with a
a a very naive view of what the
basketball industry or basketball itself
is all about
and and i really thought uh that the nba
was this
institution uh that was that was based
on all of the things that basketball had
been for me growing up a safe haven a
place of teamwork and hard work
genuineness meritocracy uh and you get
there and it's just like nah kid that
we're calling the machine and and don't
don't rail against us because we'll
squash you how do you get so so what's
the next step in this process for you
how do you get from there to now you're
running as you're running as a
republican against omar seems like
there's a big the big something big
happened in between then
well a lot of things happen but but
mainly that
the same liberal establishment that i've
watched take hold of the the cultural
narrative over the last 10 years was the
same one that tried to defame me and
poke fun at me ten years ago it's the
same one that is uh making a lot of
money in china
absolutely
and and so
you know it
i was in canada for two years i saw them
go after jordan peterson i was living
there playing for the london lightning
in london ontario in the the uh the
national basketball league canada
and um i watched that
it was the most peculiar thing because i
was a nomad up until that point was a
cultural democrat as many young black
men are growing up in these inner cities
they're cultural democrats although they
tend to be conservative really
culturally but in party affiliation they
tend to be democrat
and it was just the oddest thing to me
i'd never seen
just me personally for somehow i had
never seen people go after somebody who
was so reasonable and logical and just
seemed to be kind of a nice guy with
such obscene and ridiculous points
and i'm sitting here as a person who
fought the nba going
i have genuine points about the
establishment that we should be talking
about why are you guys going after him
about pronouns i don't get it and so i
watched that
and then i came back from canada played
in the big three
um and while i was playing in the big
three i started to talk about you know
broader
issues politically edward snowden
um julian assange the the concentration
camps in china epstein you know all this
was back in 2019
and then i wrote a book an open letter
to lebron james entitled epistle to the
king and i basically lay this out from
post-world war ii
uh all the way up until the the 2016
election of donald trump of how the
black community has been basically used
as this linchpin this cultural lynch pin
of this marxist you know this sort of
marxist globalist revolution
uh and then george floyd happened
and you were right there well the
pandemic happened first yeah and i was i
was introduced to steve bannon's show i
was introduced to his pbs frontline
interview i had already knew about him
since 2000 you know since trump ran but
i didn't really do a deep dive i still
had a surface view of him
then i saw the pbs frontline interview
and then the pandemic broke out
then i got introduced to war room like
as soon as the pandemic broke out and i
was listening to it every day it was the
most accurate
uh coverage of the pandemic at the day
was pretty much some of the only
coverage and then george floyd happened
two months later in may that was march
and then made george floyd happen what
did that change for you
go ahead i just got to bring up one
quick point as we get into george floyd
you know that story about the mural of
george floyd with the crown that got
struck by lightning exploded
i don't know a story there's a wall
there's another mural yeah and also so
in the middle was was george floyd it
was a crown over his head
on a a partly cloudy day
meteorologists reported a lightning
strike witnesses said they saw the
lightning strike and it blew out only
george floyd from the building the whole
building was like no no roof damage
that's just a freaky story that i you
know i want to bring up you know
whenever it comes to the george floyd
stuff because that's crazy
god's wrath is fast
but
like like someone staged it or something
i don't know that's crazy is that true
this is someone's stage oh no no i have
no explanation okay yeah like god's
wrath yeah i don't know man
that's what a lot of people felt like or
that that lady who was mocking the the
pandemic and then you do you see this
one the comedian
and then she just faints just like falls
back and hits her head yeah she was she
was making kind of i just wanted to
bring up the george floyd thing because
there's a that that weird moment that
happened but uh so she said jesus loves
me the most right that's when she fell
down that's right he was like
jesus loves everyone the same and yeah
you can't well you talk about
christianity
taking god's name in vain is a is a
grave sin and the wrath is quick you
really can't i don't i'm not worth
messing around i don't want to derail i
just wanted to mention that story
because it's crazy but so so now george
floyd so look the george floyd thing
happened so i i write this letter to
lebron james where i basically lay out
how black people specifically pop black
figures have been used as a three-card
monty uh to to not only
keep the black community in this
subverse you know in this place of
submission
as a community but they've been used to
now go and attack the rights of others
on the grounds of this cultural you know
this culture war and an information war
so i lay this out in the book the book's
255 pages it ends up being it's like 40
000 words or something and then george
floyd happens and my whole point to
lebron james was to say
that in the position you've been given
god-given that you have an obligation
to lead in a way that's more genuine
authentic and honest that was the whole
crooks of the book but i had to go
through the history right to because i
can't i can't just assume that he's
initiated into
this post-world war ii liberal world
order type you know i just didn't assume
that so i kind of took him through it in
good faith and then george floyd happens
and i'm like oh
i just wrote about what i need to go do
right and so
i knew from watching the narrative be be
uh you know
crafted and manipulated by the the
mainstream media that they were going to
try and hijack that moment in a variety
of ways and i knew that i was perfectly
positioned to go into
my community and lead in a way that that
changed the narrative and that's what i
did we
you know we we led several first of all
chaos broke out there was fires there
was unrest real real unrest that was on
the verge of being anarchy it was
anarchy but it was on the verge of
getting really out there
um
and in the middle of that i said i
called my basketball friends up other
guys who have big names in minnesota
sports community at least and i said we
got to go do something i'm leading this
protest if you don't come
don't shake my hand we're not friends no
more this is you guys got to put more in
and we led peaceful protests but i
wasn't gonna allow the mainstream media
or their blm subsidiary uh to dictate
the tone of the protest so instead of
going to the first precinct we went to
the federal reserve
right uh and and uh you know a lot of
these young white liberal women who want
to participate and and you know are
really passionate and active i'm sitting
on top of the stoop outside the outside
of the federal reserve and we're doing a
die in at the federal reserve and
they're looking at me like i got three
eyes like why are we here
and that's when it hit me
it hit me that
this this entire
this entire cultural war information war
is not just a byproduct of individual
people
having low morals and ethics that is a
part of it but but the establishment has
gotten really good at fooling people and
i and i was able to go out and fight
that
just by being one man
with a profile in my community that had
gained the respect of a few people in my
immediate circle
uh and who would stand around me at a
moment of chaos and turmoil and lead
physically take dominion in the
community and say hey if you have a
grievance that's great that's that's
good you should participate as a citizen
peacefully and if you want to negotiate
the social contract between you and the
state you first have to identify the
institutions that really preside over
you so we're on our way to the fed and
if you don't know what the fed is when
we get here and do this dying i'm going
to tell you a little bit about it
the mainstream media didn't even want to
cover that they they wanted it to seem
like i was a merging
civil rights activist for black lives
matter and they didn't want to give me
any air time once again to explain my
position because it's antithetical to
what they were trying to accomplish and
so that's how eventually
um in 2020 when we played with the big
three again jeff kwadnitz who was a
co-owner with ice cube used to be
partners with steve bannon and i told
jeff if you don't introduce me to steve
me and you aren't friends anymore
and jeff goes i got you he sends me the
number right away and i get hooked up
with steve we start to have great
conversations build a relationship he's
a mentor friend of mine and and the rest
is history when uh uh so uh
in in minnesota which which district are
you five cd5 yeah cd5 um what's what's
going on with that right now ellen omar
is obviously she's the incumbent is
there is there a republican primary with
a bunch of candidates um
there's two other candidates in the
field right now cece davis
uh and a woman named shakri abdirahman
and our convention is on april 2nd so
coming up here in a few weeks for the
endorsement
um and and our primary wouldn't be until
august 9 so we have a late primary and
and yeah you know i'm not certain what
those two hope to do i kind of like cece
davis just in general i kind of enjoy
her she's been on fox a few times and
i've heard her speak i met her uh one
day just randomly at a restaurant there
in our local watering hole so i enjoy
her um i don't think that she has
the understanding of of of how the
global affects the local to be effective
right now
but but the other candidate should
create abdi raman i think she's a she's
a plant i'm just going to say it you
know when you start saying i'm an
ex-veteran muslim somali immigrant who's
a battered woman i have three kids i'm a
single mom you're just playing the same
identity politics game that that the
democrats have played and she's somali i
mean i
this sounds like this would sound like
conspiracy theory but i can completely
see in a guy like soros
taking a a very similar republican
candidate
putting a republican tag on them and
running the same identity marxist
political game theory uh you know
in hedges bets
so you know i just not saying that
that's true i'm just saying that the
rhetoric from her
is like uh i'm uh a neo-liberal who's
republican and and i just think that
that's completely
inappropriate i think it's it's
manipulative dishonest and and i'm going
to do everything i can to make sure that
i'm the gop candidate now here's a
challenge this is a d26 district yeah
i still uh so there there was a lot of
people were complaining about uh
kimberly klasic you said his d26 d26
okay yeah so i mean for those aren't
familiar that's like a 26 advantage
typically for democrats
two to one uh democrat republican there
were a lot of people saying that uh kim
klasik was wasting people's money and
energy by trying to run in an area that
was so heavy a heavily democrat i
disagree man if if republicans and
thank you for that tim i appreciate that
no but listen listen if uh at the very
least the fact that you are running you
are spreading a message you are telling
people there's an alternative your time
period is an option
if
no one ever tries
in these districts to even to win at all
you lose the whole thing slowly then
there's no message but you lose the more
important thing is that
and this this is a this is a
fair criticism of the the republican
establishment i think
and myself being an athlete a lifelong
athlete and competitor if you're on the
team if us far on our team and we come
to practice every day you show up late
you smoke weed during the week you party
you don't get sleep when we get to
practice
you don't know the plays
you you know you you come in late right
you when when the guy in front of you
goes and and does what he's supposed to
do you don't do it you don't pay
attention to him the coach is talking
you're playing with your hair or telling
a joke
all that i can deduct from that is that
you don't want to win
you don't want to play and you don't
want to win
uh and i think the republican
establishment has to be
you know there has to be real
um
there has to be a very real skepticism
of the genuineness of the republican
platform
at the party level right now because
where is the evidence that they want to
actually win these elections
i think they just want to stay there's
no urgency i don't sense any urgency
from candidates anymore from people that
are already in they're just trying to
collect a paycheck and stay in office
they spend two years either that or
they're in running for re-election
either that or they're interested they
are in on it on what when you say uh the
the post
world the post uh
the new liberal award order do you think
they're getting bought out like what by
and don't realize they're getting bought
out by i think i think a lot of them are
the controlled opposition and look i
don't want to be disparaging to the
republican party because i just got here
i'm just a third party who came from the
void as a nomad and renegade
anti-establishment guy and i'm saying
that the evidence of the republicans
trying to actually put forward an effort
to really win and fight in these
districts that they say are unwinnable
is is so few and far between that i
can't come up with any other
reason
that either they're just losers some of
them or they're actually in on it and
they're getting a kickback for the for
the managed decline let me let me tell
you man in west virginia
second most trump supporting state these
schools are all woke the school boards
are woke and there are people who are
conservative who think those crazy
problems don't affect my kids because
we're in west virginia they don't go to
the meetings it turns out these these
these schools you've got all of the
critical race theory you've got all the
wokeness gender ideology
you've got the left the democrats and
the progressives going into red areas
spreading the word recruiting trying to
slip it in under the the
the
under the under the door
in big in in urban areas republicans are
told don't bother fighting at all you're
wasting time and energy it's a it's a
lopsided it's asymmetrical warfare how
do you how did they plan their way look
and here's the here's the other thing
the democrat platform the the
neo-liberal marxist globalist platform
has a better sales pitch in the physical
realm
it says anything goes
anything that your little heart desires
you can have and there is no judgment
about it
that's a good sales pitch for the
physical realm for the here and now
which is kind of how the bible becomes
profound and saying that this thing is
all going to go to hell eventually
because
people become more interested
in their wickedness than they are in
their their faith in god so
we
my point in bringing that up is not to
to to say that this needs to become a
theocracy or to say you know to try and
be a bible thumper but what i'm saying
is that it's very clear
that that that paradigm
should incentivize and make it even more
urgent that the republicans have to
fight at every place that they possibly
can because if not you already you have
to transform hearts and minds and see a
bigger a
give people deeper meaning to their life
because the drugs and the fast
validation and reward is on the democrat
side it is it is true that george soros
provided funding for local district
attorneys in a variety of places around
the country that that's i think the
guardian reported on that fox news got
all mad when newt gingrich said it and
he was like what like this is like
mainstream reporting that's doing this
so you've got
powerful leftist organizations and
institutions going into conservative
areas changing how the laws are being
enforced changing how schools are
teaching these kids florida for instance
right i mean they're passing these laws
because they have the political power to
do so and it is an issue but hearing it
in west virginia people don't want to
believe it
republicans
need to be going into blue districts and
and doing what you're doing
coming on shows uh writing books putting
out the messages speaking
and just in general
doing the same thing where are the
conservatives moderates or libertarians
i mean come on libertarians
let's get some libertarians to go to go
run for school board in a blue in a blue
area yeah they don't they don't do it
i mean i come from a cultural democrat
community and i can just say that the
conservative representation as i was
growing up is completely non-existent
and and so i'm 30. so it's not just in
the here and now that the republicans
haven't pushed back or or dedicated or
invested in the minority vote and i
don't say minority to play uh
intersectional politics i'm just saying
that minorities as demographic latinos
and blacks make up a significant portion
of the voter base and they i wouldn't i
had no idea what the republican platform
is is and that's not all due to the
democrats or the mainstream media that's
due to a laziness and an inaction on
their behalf so i'm happy to be able to
fight you know for that now whenever uh
you know sheamus is on the show fairly
often and we'll talk about religion
and we'll often point out to people
where i'm in conversations maybe like
off the show or whatever a lot of the
arguments made by uh secular liberals
and atheists tend to be a caricature of
the beliefs of christians concerned
christian conservatives or you know
christian groups because they don't
interact with them typically typically
what you'll see is you know we we talk
about there will be a meme
ascribing a belief to conservatives that
isn't true and then you actually ask
someone who's a regular churchgoer and
they'll be like we don't we don't do
that
i think the issue is
one thing they don't really do is go
into these areas and just meet and talk
with people be active in the school
these school meetings
actively uh campaign put up billboards
try and actually run you might not be
able to win
and herein lies the problem who's going
to want to invest you know millions of
dollars into a congressional campaign in
a d plus 26 district but if you do it
once you do it twice maybe the third
time you can take that district
well listen i think we got a very good i
hear what you're saying and i agree with
you i really look at miami you look at
miami yeah my miami district flipped
republican and it was like d plus 20 or
something let me see if i can pull that
one up i agree with you and i think the
republican party or the free people
let's say in this country
um should should definitely invest in in
putting up the fight
um and i believe in the war of attrition
but i will say that i think we have a
good chance of beating her in this
election i think you're interesting
because you have a unique perspective on
mental health i have a feeling that a
lot of what people are going through now
is there's a lot of mental health issues
i went through in like 2006-7 when i got
into social media i started doing
internet videos and i went slowly went
crazy rapidly went crazy after like two
years i wanted to kill myself literally
i was like this is it there's nothing to
live for at this point the world
economic war it's taken over i'm just
here to die that was my thought it was
horrifying and i think so many people
are going through that right now this
despair and then they're medicating and
i mean you talk about the
the medical global military or medical
industry you name that as one of your
five heads on the hydra the food and
medical industry combine the sugar
industry uh the food is the medical
industrial complex dude if if these
people that and i think because they're
they're numbed and they're afraid
they're just voting for what the tv
tells them to vote for true
they need a voice that they can relate
to here's here i'll say this
i agree with you um so so when the
globalists for example say you're going
to own nothing and be happy they don't
mean we're going to make your lives more
meaningful
or or or more healthy they're saying
we're going to make the material high so
good that you're not going to notice
we're stealing from you you're not gonna
notice that we're [ __ ] you right and
that that's really what they mean when
they say it and
what they're relying on ultimately is to
say we're big and you're small
so so even if you know in a lot of
cultural democrats and liberals do
and are amenable to the idea that there
is a system or the man or an elite that
are screwing them but their mo is that i
have no power in that game all i can
that's how that's part of how uh a lot
of the politics at the grassroots level
have devolved into the identity politics
because they say well if i can't win at
a big scale then i'm going to make you
say my pronouns and that's how they feel
power that
now i just want to point out uh
florida's 27th congressional district
currently has a republican maria elvira
salazar it's a d plus four i think she
was on uh with tucker though recently
wasn't wasn't she was that her i don't
remember people were maybe that was her
but uh d plus four not d plus 20 so i
was wrong about that and maybe you're a
republican you're like i think we can
get a d plus four we can try but this
was considered safe democrat
in in all of the polling they were like
it's it's heavy blue it's not gonna flip
and then it did i think there actually
was another uh district that flipped as
well it was two districts maybe maybe
one was that this is a barack obama
district this is a joe biden and hillary
clinton district that now has a
republican representing it we can't
write the
here's part of what's happened with the
republican party i believe i'll say this
i think because they have a fundamental
um
that there that there's a there's a
thread of christianity baked into the
republican party
that
they rightfully they they rightfully now
see the order of charity in the proper
way
that the order of charity is local
they've just been pushed
to their little corners and now the
order of charity is what he's saying is
right around them and they're going we
don't have to go back into the belly of
the beast with the ministry of truth and
i think republicans and many christians
have forgotten about the importance of
ministry and that's what we're talking
about here and that's what i did when
george floyd the george floyd situation
happened i took a ministry of truth
into the belly of the beast and i
confronted the lies rebuke and refute so
and i'm not i'm not condemning
republicans and christians on the right
for for doing that because i understand
that the order of charity is proper in
that the order of charity is first that
which is local to you um yourself your
family and your immediate community um
but we are at war and and the rules
change when you're at war and we're in a
culture ward and information war and as
you see we're in a and we're in a
kinetic guns up war as well
yeah the 26th district is also d plus
one and that's a republican right now as
well so those projections were way off
people can make a change if you go out
and you actually fight for it
absolutely yeah rapidly too with the
internet look at the look at the ncla
tournament right now look at saint
peter's the 15th seed
oh come on they're in the sweet 16 man i
i just come from the sports world where
the underdog is
not only can you win
but it's so it feels so damn good
when you're the underdog and you win
anyway so just as a sportsman and a
competitor
this was the only i could have run in a
district that was more red i could have
run in a statewide race where we had a
bigger republican constituency governor
senate um but but to go into the belly
to beast first is honorable
it's it's actually fruitful in my
opinion i moved to new york city after
college uh 2001. september 5th six days
before the buildings came down and uh my
dad was like you're going into the belly
of the beast ian yeah put this twenty
dollars in your side praise god that's
all right here we go brother let me pull
up this story it seems to be it's just a
weird story but it's a belly of the
beast man we got this story from the
daily mail ben and jerry's manager is
accused of dousing mentally ill homeless
person with a bucket of water because
she was crying on the sidewalk outside
of the store in san francisco
i don't even want to play the video um
it's just a crying homeless person
dude apparently comes out and splashes
water on them but there's there's so
much here obviously there's like a
culture uh canceled culture outrage
going on over this and people on social
media like how dare you but man does
this hit at the very serious problems of
cities like san francisco with
representation like nancy pelosi granted
she's at the federal level but still
this is her city she doesn't seem to
care about it
you've got the homeless crisis you've
got the drug crisis you've got the
failed policies you've got human waste
all over the streets and then you've got
people saying that california is five
years ahead of the rest of the country
so you look at stories like this
and it's like this ben and jerry's
manager it's like a regular guy just ben
and jerry's like the ice cream yeah yeah
okay yeah the woke ice cream company the
ice cream company that's right the
extremely politically correct woke ice
cream company
as long as it's not homeless people what
was that really awful flavor they had it
was woke and had like a weird thing in
it i can't remember what it was i'll try
to have cinnamon in it no no what i love
cinnamon what are you talking about
i absolutely love cinnamon that's weird
you are so wrong i am offended that
someone cinnamon bun ice cream soda suck
on a cinnamon stick before no that's
pretty good but oh you ever do the
cinnamon challenge you guys ever do that
take a scoop of cinnamon and you put it
in your mouth don't i'm not suggesting
you do it just don't breathe out your
nose yeah i think it was a shake
i'm talking about
what happens to a city when you don't
fight for it you lose it yeah and and
then some i mean
would you describe san francisco as
being lost or maybe something worse
it's it's just it devolves into satanism
i lived there for a little while you
guys ever lived there i've been there
i've i've never lived there but i've
passed through for periods of time it
wasn't as bad when i was there this was
a long long time ago it was like 2015
for me and to be fair to like what
you're saying you have to keep fighting
because the uh i mean i hate to make
this a left verse right i think they're
not going to stop like i still get like
i am shocked by how many door-to-door
campaigners i would get in minnesota in
areas that were safe blue right
and the amount of messages you get from
you know this is so and so from this
campaign and you're like stop messaging
me and you're still going to keep
getting them and you're still going to
keep getting because they never stop so
if you're going to at least try to make
a change how can you just say oh well
this district is clearly blue why would
i even try they're going to try they're
going to go into those red districts and
they're going to keep trying whether
it's through the educational system
whether it's door-to-door campaigning
sending you messages they will not stop
it's cultural on every level so we can't
you know again i hate making this a left
versus right thing because i don't
consider myself a republican or democrat
or any of that but you can't stop this
okay
there you go say so yeah yeah so like
you you have to at least be willing to
fight for those what's the point you're
just giving in yeah no i mean and these
people aren't messing around they're not
kidding around i mean i i think the
whole three card monty manipulation is
whoever the voters are now let's guilt
them into voting democrat uh because
republicans are racist and and while
that takes place
we will we will use those wins to
systematically go into
uh the communities at the grassroots
educational school level and
indoctrinate the next generation so that
we won't even have to we won't even have
to lie anymore we don't even have to
manipulate them they'll believe the
things we believe the three-car monty is
like that game where you have three cups
with like a ball under it four cards or
whatever and so you're saying they're
using the the black community as like a
distraction and they're getting people
to look away so that they can move the
card the holocaust and adolf hitler are
the scapegoat and the justification for
new world order black people are the
justification for authoritarianism
authoritarian
church of lgbtq anti-human american
politics same game
just the same game
i got a question about this right that
they uh
some politician recently said in the
past couple of years that the for
democrats the the the way to the black
voters through the church and and i've
you've heard that before right yeah i'm
live
but i'm wondering why hat 50 50 sure i
get what they're saying but it's a lie
but you constantly hear about these
democrats going to these black churches
to get votes or whatever and they say
that oh it's because the churches have
sway in the community and then but now
overblown i think right right well tell
me about that why why where does that
drink i think the biggest i think the
biggest um
two things one it's through pop culture
it's it's through the the subtle
um
very
underhanded
presentation of a white supremacy
patriarchy
and that if you vote republican then
that is the patriarchy and so black
people are ju but it's also the
republicans don't feel the need to clear
that up right they haven't felt the need
to clear that story up and i get it i
mean if they
it's just not going to win the game i
was like morgan freeman he was like
don't call me a black man i'm not going
to call you a white man we're just men
yeah
i mean look here's the thing with the i
see we can't we there's a very real
from a biology standpoint i don't like
on the right when people say well
race isn't even real like race is only
really okay go to state penitentiary and
see how people group themselves out of
self-defense and preservation race is
real and people group themselves in
certain ways based on how they look and
like cultural values and there's nothing
wrong with that what's wrong is when you
give yourself the right to to violate
somebody else's natural god-given
inalienable human rights based on their
race there's nothing wrong to say you're
you're a you're a mixed race man
but you look like my grandmother looks
whiter than you by the way she was
norwegian but you're a white man i'm a
black man and that's fine it was
interesting you said what was that based
on how they look and how their cultural
values are but not really about who
their ancestors were right it really
it's it's an alludes to that illusion of
what they look like but see because the
ancestor thing once you get there it all
gets murky because what is white if you
go ancestral yeah irish spanish italian
your guy who who's the guy who can't
pick me up no oh oh uh i don't know who
picked you up i've been brian bryan
brian yeah my guy brian my guy brian
he's in the front seat of the car he's
driving and he goes uh yeah i'm italian
yeah and i go
right but he was like but i joined the
army in the german and i was on a
military base so is he technically
he's a battalion citizen he's americans
what i'm saying is that what is white
gets murky black is different i'll tell
you why because black were
full swath brought over
in a transatlantic slave trade and we
lost our indigenous ties but a lot of
the white
immigrants that came to this country
came with those cultural ethnic uh
heritages still intact so
yeah i mean it gets murky when you go to
the ancestral place i would say that if
you look at communities um black blacks
tend to be grouped in certain areas but
that's changing there's gentrification
but there's nothing wrong with saying
that there's race i don't like when p
the right sometimes has this boomerang
effect
where whatever the absurd cultural
narrative is on the left they just go
opposite out of
that happened with the the florida
parental rights and education bill i
started seeing a bunch of conservatives
following
following the narrative of the left the
bill stopped teachers from saying you're
teaching kids about being gay or
whatever which is just absolutely not
true the bill in no way stops teachers
from walking up to a kid and saying
these things and i'm like
the the bill came out
it was a debate and amendments over it
and then the bill that was seeking to be
passed had says nothing to do about
banning the word gay just says you can't
have you know sex ed effectively for
pre-k to third grade
but the democrats ran with this
narrative because it was effective and
then i saw republicans arguing that
narrative and i'm like
it's made up you're not arguing anything
because there's there's nothing there
yeah but they they they walk into these
traps yeah well it's just you know it's
part of its laziness um you know it's
just
intellectual laziness and we built a
society that makes it very hard to be a
deep critical thinker yeah i like
talking about the differences of
genetics of species of people because of
the ancestry like that's fascinating to
me that sickle cell anemia for instance
was showing up more readily in like the
black community in the 60s or something
because of some genetic change
difference of genetics of ancestry i
don't know but it's interesting to talk
about with everybody any race color in
person of any language it's interesting
stuff like it's a good thing no too i
think the issue with uh
racism we've talked to a lot of people
about it the reason why it's it's very
obviously rejected by most people
especially amount of times is that you
know if you have a guy from somalia and
a guy from say haiti they might both
have dark skin but be wildly different
in terms of their genetics you know one
guy might be small
might be tall but then if you have laws
or policy based on race
how do you actually determine someone it
sees them as the same person yeah it's
actually racist to do it that way
to see the somali and the haitian person
as both being black or african well
that's exactly it because if if you were
to try to make an argument about like
well the average height or it's like
well
i mean some people from you know are
black and short and some people are
black and tall right and so that's
that's that's the problem with race is
that it really really is superficial
granted i think uh a conversation around
well it's superficial unless 30 million
black babies are are genocided at
planned parenthood over 60 years can you
talk about that well you got a question
that's where race gets real real for me
um so you know my my point to my
conservative republican counterparts is
to say stop saying racism isn't real
because you're giving these neoliberals
an out that's crazy because i thought it
like oh yeah i think of it as a class
issue but i think you're right that
there was some serious racism going on
by the people look at the results well
wasn't that early 30 million black
babies at a planned parenthood there'll
be more babies to die at planned
parenthood in the next two weeks than
died in the ukraine
wow maybe not two weeks let's say a
month two months when does what when
does life begin
it's a tough one i mean
at conception that's what i'd say
spiritually i think i think if we're
talking look
i'm against i'm anti-abortion
but
we we've we've put the law into motion
and there's a trajectory that makes it
hard to
undo without potential unintended
consequences so i don't i don't i'm not
going to say that to 12 weeks
is i don't know what vibe was to me as a
christian i'm just going to say
that maybe the government shouldn't have
the choice but culturally spiritually
and philosophically for me personally to
have a black mother a black grandmother
black sisters
that are we failed as a black community
one but we failed as an american culture
that women would choose abortion so
there's two separate things to go on
there i think one of the two most
important questions
that were asked to uh judge katanji
brown jackson what is a woman
she said she couldn't provide a
definition yeah and that to me is
absolutely absurd she was also asked and
it's not a celebration that she's become
a supreme court justice at that point
right but go ahead the other question if
you don't know what a woman is then why
are we celebrating that a black woman is
the supreme court exactly exactly yeah
the other question was about when life
begins
we need to have
we we need to to the best of our
abilities try and quantify
uh the world around us so that we can
create effective policy and help protect
people and grant them civil rights if we
can't define a phrase we can't protect
it i agree so in the instance of
abortion and um what is a woman
the reason in my opinion the left won't
give you a definition they'll say i
don't i don't know when life begins
maybe after birth or something they have
no clearly defined point is because
that way they can't do moral wrong right
because if you say life begins a
conception it's a moral wrong at any
point more relativism yeah that's the
that's the linchpin of their whole
ideology now they're saying after birth
and it's just like that way they can
have late term abortions they say what
is omen oh i can't answer that because
then you can have you can you can sort
of massage various institutions in this
country
i think it's it's easily defined
in terms of what they're doing
if a judge can't tell you what a woman
is but then in the same
meet in the same hearing with only a few
minutes say roe v wade is important it
protects a woman's right to terminate
her pregnancy completely absurd you
can't use the word woman in that
sentence with when you can't even define
what it is see but but whatever it
empowers them what you're doing is
you're debunking the logical fallacy and
you do it well i watch you often i'm
like i'm a secretary i appreciate it
you're one of the best in the business
that debunking the logical fallacies i i
really enjoy it but i'm just trying to
understand no no but there's no tell me
the rules there are no rules i know
let's just say what it is they don't
care about the logic right they don't
care because the logic to to
to disavow yourself from the logos which
is a christian idea right the logos to
disavow yourself and detach yourself
from the logos is to give yourself carb
blanche to apply morals and ethics
however you see fit when you see fit
advantageous in most cases for you to be
cruel and predatory and immoral and
let's just draw a hard line
inception add inception if you abort a
child
you conception conception i'm sorry yeah
conception if you abort a child
you take the innocence of a child well
that's that's a grave sin the debate
would be it is alive i kind of agree
that it's life when it's conceived but
is it when does it become human
conception conception well hey you
didn't let him answer you answered forum
oh i don't i thought you were i mean the
only reason the only reason i pause is
because when i think of human i wouldn't
accept the premise that the gold on the
left is to even properly identify or or
outline what human is like he's saying
and i think that in general they have a
very anti-human spirit and this abortion
thing is is part and parcel of it so i
wouldn't even accept the premise that
that they are in any way concerned with
the idea of humans or humanity they're
not let me let me ask you a question
they actually think human life in
general
it can be deduced down to suffering and
uncertainty it's a it's a yeah it's kind
of like they're at war i think we you're
saying mental war like mental siege
people really feel like they're at war
so they're acting like it and like you
want to talk about taking life if you
feel like you're at war there are no
rules
let me ask you a question
do you have a soul
um i i believe it's not mine but i
believe there's an energy field around
me that i would consider my soul or a
soul that i is my soul you know do you
feel it
sometimes you deal with heat
you you can feel it moving through me
you feel that there is an uh some kind
of energy within you that that is
intrinsic to you or
i was thinking about this because that's
god buddy
check this out magnetic vibration or
something that's a bit it's a higher
power i've talked to people who've said
no i say do you have a soul and say i
don't believe in that no i don't
and for a long time i thought
they just don't believe or maybe they
don't know the things i know and then i
thought about them like maybe people who
genuinely don't feel that they really
don't have one
but i'm not saying i'm not saying it's a
moral judgment of the person no i get
what you're saying i'm saying like
that's an existential bond
but they're sensationally muted to it
maybe maybe maybe their connection is
muted or whatever but i was just
thinking about this because there's a
psychological phenomenon of product
projection we assume the people we talk
with know the things we know we assume
they believe the things we do and if
they don't if they say otherwise they
must be lying if i say i know trump is
crooked and then someone else says no
he's not they must be lying because
everyone knows they're they they project
only what they can sense of themselves
yeah thinking about that i was like i
mean
i've had experiences that i can only
describe as like um
visions and epiphanies and feelings
metaphysical
that you know are
metaphysical perhaps indescribable in
some ways that give me the feeling of i
have a soul and there is a god i'm not
theistic i don't believe in scripture or
bibles or anything like that i just feel
like there's a greater power and i've
had experience in my life i've felt
things and then i thought about well if
someone tells me they've never
experienced and they don't feel it maybe
it's not that they're cut off or that
either of us are wrong it's that they
genuinely don't have that maybe it's
this it's just that simple and i should
project
them not everybody has it so then the
idea is that it does exist but that not
everyone has it some people are npcs
that was the aiden paladin did a great
video where she talks about how that's
like a that's the matrix motif yeah she
talks about a study about uh some people
just don't have an inner monologue right
that's right
or or i'll give i'll give a spiritual um
scenario
maybe the aggregation of sin across time
um has deadened the spiritual connection
uh at mass and that some individuals um
unexpectedly and and completely randomly
are born without a spiritual connection
but
my my response to that would be to say
that individuals can be brought back as
a christian individuals can be brought
back into faith and grace uh when
introduced and practicing that there is
a there is a physical way to practice to
become reconnected clearly
plaque off your brain i have a crazy
idea ian you're gonna love it thanks i
have a crazy idea i was just you know
thinking about dmt and um i'm absolutely
fascinated by it that's why i think you
know joe rogan's fascinated that's why
people talk about it so often
because you hear these stories from say
um
well i just from anybody prominent
stories that they're entities machine
elves or beings you take dmt you meet
them you go you you blast off or you go
beyond the veil as it's been described
and you meet beings who will tell you
secrets who will tell you things or make
deals with you or whatever some are evil
some are not i started thinking about
that and i'm like if dmt is naturally
occurring in your brain
then are you really dreaming or are you
getting a small glimpse of the window
beyond the veil
of course dmt makes people force right
through it
the spirit molecule or whatever as i
describe it what if
some people don't produce enough to
create a strong connection with whatever
is beyond the veil that makes a lot of
sense some people produce a lot more so
they naturally have a deep connection to
some kind of alex jones um
i like this idea i do people who are uh
uh deeply spiritual who can feel that
scent that feeling within them of a soul
or spirit people who can visualize who
can just come up with with beautiful
works of art they've got some kind of
connection to a vast network beyond them
now maybe this is just an idea i'm not
saying it's true i'm saying considering
we're exploring what dmt is we're doing
these research this research now and
there's interesting things about it
what if that was it some people just
naturally produce more and that connects
them better
with you know something greater than us
and some people don't so they can't
sense or feel it there's been conspiracy
theory that ca fluoride calcifies the
pineal gland you guys ever hear that
theory it's been around for 20 years or
something i've read about it i don't
know for sure if it actually does but it
sounds like internet mumbo jumbo might
be but it's well here's one that's where
the deal is fluoride is a neurotoxin and
the pineal glands where the dmt is
produced in the brain i think your
muscles produce it too your stomach even
maybe i think here's one i know i know
from being on anti-anxiety medications
such as fluoxetine which is prozac which
is one of the most prescribed which is
one of the most prescribed drugs in the
in the world
in america let's say um but it's all of
the ssris the serotonin and selective
reuptake inhibitors um are are proven to
bring testosterone down
so there there are i mean what the what
we're putting into our body
uh can't be dismissed out of hand as the
overall effect it's having on society
but but the question is is how much of
that has been intentionally engineered
and that's like we were talking soul
earlier now i don't know if that's soul
if we're talking soul if you're just
talking about your ability to function
normally but i have you know we were
talking earlier about substance abuse
and absolutely ssris uh whether you're
talking xanax uh prozac anything from
those families my mind is with opiates
any of those dulls your senses and if
we're talking about your ability to feel
the world around you
which you know whether you're talking
your soul
whatever that is uh your ability to
understand and feel the world as it
happens to you is deadened and is
quieted by those chemicals and then you
have to talk about whether that was uh
intentionally done into the community
into our communities if it was done you
know certain people are gonna have brain
imbalances i was on uh i was on prozac
when i was younger uh eventually went
off it and had took a lot of years to
get off of everything entirely yeah um
and i was i tell the story a lot like
the first time when i realized that i
could go outside without going through
any withdrawal symptoms i cried for like
maybe the first time in
10 15 years not because nothing sad had
happened to me before that because there
was no actual reason or way for my body
to process trauma uh before that so if
you're talking about coming back to the
world that was the first time in a lot
of years i had felt like soul i know
that pain it feels like when you have
that level of mental you know mental uh
health struggles anxiety depression
when there are moments when you when you
when you're with yourself and you really
can
identify that fog yeah that you're
living
and when you come out of it it's like
whoa then you really realize like that
was really a deep fog i was in
i just think that there's a spiritual
component to it like like like you're
laying out and you know i i here here's
my thing i think where we're going with
science
where where we're headed with science by
and large at this global you know
science technocratic uh behest
is more leaning towards anti-human
uh
attitude um and not and not
not trying to use this science to really
and genuinely figure out um the link
between us and the spiritual world
i don't think that that's what this
transhuman movement is about i think
this trans-human movement is to phase
people out altogether because they're
nihilistic about the value of humanity i
think well greg braden is a good uh
scientist that seems to be on the right
path he is has acknowledged a lot of
like he's not into that stuff but he
understands like the power of the heart
and the electromagnetic frequency that
it produces and stuff he's a he's really
fascinating uh many scientists have
written about the next iteration of life
beyond self-replicating proteins and
multicellular organisms is
self-replicating machines that can
outlive all of us
so
i read this one story about what what
year one million would look like
and it basically said that all human
life and all life has been wiped off of
earth but there are self-replicating
massive machines that float around the
universe taking millions or billions of
years to travel to the next energy
deposit absorb it and then replicate
itself yeah it's just it's offensive and
that's it as a christian it's offen it
offends me dude i mean that conception
of life or or just any any
any conception of a future where
humanity no longer that's not arrogance
that's to understand and appreciate the
divine gift that god has
has has given humanity uh being human
and any any conception where we try and
justify our role
and and the destruction of humanity is
is a heresy and a blasphemy against god
it offends me it feels like we figured
out how to hack our brains as humans we
our brains expanded to a point where we
figured out how to make them expand
faster so we we accelerated the
expansion kind of like kicking a fusion
generator on and now we're just so
exceedingly evolved relative to other
animals on earth it's really easy i
think unique i think is one way to look
at it look uh metaverse we've been
harping on for the past couple of weeks
it's coming now a lot of people say you
know tim metaverse is not popular yeah
mark zuckerberg's is not popular but
when neural link can plug your brain in
i i see it like there are many powerful
individuals who wish they could just
make you do something but they can't you
have rights and you have
physical control of your body so they
can come at you and say do it or else
and you can say no and then what do they
do get get some guys trip oh man how
about
we can't be gods
but if we plug everyone into the
metaverse
now you can be now you can cut off their
finances now you can
eliminate them from the server just
you're outright banned you're in
if you everyone willfully goes into the
metaverse you can be banned from it and
now you're not participating in the
economy and the information network in
society in any way terms and conditions
absolutely and also in the metaverse
they can also be like um we're going to
make your voice half as loud we're going
to make everyone the same height
everyone wants to do as tall as they're
told and if i'm the owner
if you're mark zuckerberg
you can be sitting you can be sitting in
this metaverse public square and someone
comes in and says i need to tell
everybody about this oil spill and he
goes
and you're gone that's what he's been
doing not maybe not necessarily him
personally but facebook has been purging
big tech like political ideas
because we already exist in a digital
space in terms of our political
conversations big tech has already shown
us what they will do if given more power
over you know i was thinking about the
most dangerous thing it's the biggest
existential threat to humanity in my
opinion becoming a god in that universe
it's like i would you want to become a
god in someone else's universe where
they control your godhood i don't know
but it's kind of like growing up in the
united states you're like in the united
states you can the american dream you
can grow up and become everything you
ever wanted you become a billionaire but
you're still in their universe if the us
government wants to shut you down and
cut you out of swift and drop a bomb on
your house they have the legal authority
to do it so you're you're a god elon
musk is a god in their universe right
now so what's how's it different that's
it's sort of creating a fractal of that
with the metaverse it's another
authoritarian thing where you get the
illusion of being god if you work hard
enough and play by the rules the more
the more they expand
the more they push our lives into
digital spaces the more rights you will
lose
and you better be ready to fight for
those rights because they're going to
keep defaulting on it's a private
business you don't have to be in it
but right now that's the biggest that's
one of the biggest scams that's
that's that's uh socialism uh that
that's socialism masquerading as being
anti-corporate but at the global scale
socialism actually becomes the highest
level of corporation
and that that's that's what the
progressive left is really trying to do
in in their political strategy
is say you know the bernie sanders even
the bernie sanders crowd and you know my
steve who i love you know dearly he he
gives bernie his credit for for you know
some of his positions but i i see
bernie's position in aoc and these
people as not being anti-corporate i see
that they're in on the the game to merge
government and state uh uh i mean state
and corporation at the global level and
thus ushering the serfdom which i know
steve has talked to and agrees with too
um but but them saying they're
anti-corporate is just uh
uh uh you know a problem with the
premise that that socialism
you know that
the problem with the premise is that the
state already isn't the highest form of
government many people don't see i mean
the highest former corporation many
people don't see the state as a
corporation
in this it's an organ i don't care if
you call it a corporation a government
or whatever organizations yeah
hierarchical organizations that can that
have control that have power that can
exert that power they want to make us
serfs slaves and why would we believe
that that
megalomaniacs wouldn't have the ambition
to domineer uh you know lesser lesser
individuals i mean that's just that's
just adds up one two three yeah the
government's saying
corporation
capital c is a different type of that's
an efficient tech companies are going to
offer you your wildest dreams to plug
your brain into their networks they've
already done it we're getting close you
can go online
you can you can make your profile
picture whatever you want to be that's
giving a lot of people some satisfaction
that you know catfishing for instance is
ridiculous some people just want to do
it it's scary but they're going to come
with the neural link in the metaverse
and they're going to say
you can be
a pirate captain
just install this chip and you will be
the private captain you also have to
have a job and everything but play these
games you go in they own you
ready player one ready player one it's
weird what's strange to me is how many
people and i guess i mean it's it's not
shocking to me because i was the guy 10
years ago saying the mental health
epidemic is here and it's going to get
worse and people are like
mainstream liberal
you know
writers and journalists were going what
do you mean everybody's suffering from
mental illness i'm like what do you mean
what do i mean i mean
the evidence is clear but
um
i i see
um this whole ready player once in there
as being more dangerous than people
think on a practical level very soon
because
the neurolink situation for example
nobody if you're not going to own
anything but be happy
that means you're certainly not going to
own your neural link you're going to be
leasing it that's right and if you're
leasing it that means they own it that
means now they own a piece of your brain
i think what will have to happen to make
neural link a thing is they'll need to
be able to wirelessly connect you
so
assuming it's possible i don't know if
it is
right now what they're doing with neural
link is they're these very thin um you
know metal i guess you'd call them
cables threads maybe threads that
lightly tap into the brain and then
track data and they've hooked up to i
think pigs to track their vitals and
stuff like that they cut up in like a
quarter-sized circle and then they sew
these threads into like just under the
top layer of the brain that was about a
year ago that's where the tech was at so
it looks like what we have right now is
is
basic read only if we're getting to the
point where you can read and write into
a brain allowing you to have experiences
that means there's going to have to be a
calibration for your brain because
everyone's brain's different we don't
have one human code it's everyone's
brain has different amounts of you know
chemicals in it or whatever but getting
to that point i i think implants aren't
going to work
it's going to have to be something they
can you can you can wear on your head
that it wirelessly projects things into
your mind which i'm not sure is possible
but the idea that people are going to go
and get fitted within with you know
surgery to have something i don't see as
being realistic a lot of people aren't
going to want that surgery unless
unless they create an economic situation
where in order to not do it would be so
uh
what would make you so disadvantaged
that you feel left out of society many
people will do many things to feel a
sense of belonging to the society around
them okay that's that's getting your
testicles or penis cut off because you
think you feel like a woman is that is
there any job you can work right now if
you don't have a cell phone
i'm sure there i'm sure it's not
absolute there are some but also factory
jobs and stuff but they're going to be
like post covert is getting it's getting
shortened
they're going to be like i tried calling
you where were you you weren't answering
your phone and you're like i don't have
a cell phone like what why you're not
allowed to not be available all the time
now you have to always be able to answer
your phone otherwise they're going to
say well why don't you have one it makes
no sense i'll tell you this though um
if we get to the point where they can do
read write into your brain but you'll
need a surgical implant
if they go
if i'll tell you this
if they went right now and said
neurolink is available to surgical
implant it costs 2 000
lasts you for life and you can
physically experience
x-men skyrim
eldon ring whatever
you're gonna have millions of young men
outright being like save me from this i
don't want to be here anymore this sucks
i don't know about young women
because they're they're you know what we
see with instagram they're they're much
more motivated by you know social
behaviors men would be like
just get me away from it i don't want to
deal with it a lot of gameplay footage
on youtube and
one of the guys that i watch in
particular is like sign me up number one
i'm first in line get me in there
because he's games for a living that's
right the whole problem with this is
that the
we've we've created a culture where
people don't see any value in suffering
or hard work or or that's right you know
and as an athlete it just offends me i'm
just i just can't get beyond it it's
offensive i'm like guys i hear you true
that you you got to fall you have to
love the process of working hard uh
putting some sweat and some time and
some energy and commitment into
something and seeing the result that's
beautiful i think like along with what
you were saying brett that the love the
joy that is lost when you're medicated
like i i was just re i just for the
first time saw this article from the
guardian microplastics found in human
blood for first time this is from like
four days ago you talk about like drug
being drugged by by our own refuse
i don't know if you consider that a drug
at this point but if it's in your blood
and it's not a food then
but also it's the it's the narrative
that it's not worth it anymore there's a
lot of that going on that no matter how
hard you work you know your parents
bought a house when they were 26 and
they each worked a part-time job and
paid for college and the idea is now
that no matter how hard you work the
system is rigged against you and hard
work is actually seen as a negative
because it's almost like you're a sucker
you're buying into the system i i think
they want you to feel that way that's
what i'm saying they want you that
that's a narrative that they've spun
very very well corporations want you
dependent so you buy their products
government wants you dependent so you
give them their votes the last thing
they want is for someone to be like i
don't need anything from you i can go
i think one of the things that greatly
benefits me throughout life is that
i don't really have anything to lose now
granted if i have a family that's where
they get people you know they go after
your family your kids your wife or
otherwise but for me it's like yo i've
experienced hardship to the point where
it doesn't scare me yeah that you know
so
without anything left to lose you you
can you have the opportunity to you have
the opportunity to explore and then
eventually stumble upon better
opportunities take bigger risks and go
for these things
they want you to feel like if you lose
your job you're screwed you're done your
life is over that's not true and that
that that's the motive again from a
spiritual standpoint that's the motif of
heaven collapsing for people when heaven
collapses for you the idea of a heaven
of a paradise of something to look
forward to all you have left is the here
and now
which makes all your action and your
your entire
that creates anxiety and despair because
the here and now is fleeting and we all
know it we grow up knowing it we were we
were born with the intuition that the
here and now is going to be short and
potentially cruel and unfair and yeah
that would make somebody anxious and
depressed and then we get into dopamine
hits and instant gratification and the
fact that people don't live for farther
out they're living just from one hit to
the other whether it's social media
whether it's drugs but they don't see it
they don't see it as a
uh you know a lot of people don't see it
as this sort of if if you if you created
put up on the screen somebody who was
just addicted to crack right and they
just couldn't help
to to have to do cracking just how that
desperation would look on on a tv screen
people who are using social media in
this tech this way don't see themselves
in that regard at all i read this
article in a skateboard magazine as a
kid i could be misremembering but it was
called what now
and uh breit will totally get this
because you skate um well you played but
this was skateboarding magazine but same
thing in this regard it said you're a
skateboarder and you've decided to do
some kind of trick down a set of stairs
and you fight for it and you fail and
you try again and you fail and you fail
and you fail and every time you fail
you're getting frustrated you're getting
tired maybe you leave maybe maybe you
come back but sooner or later you land
that trick
and for a few seconds it feels really
really good it's the greatest feeling in
the world but then a few seconds later
it's gone and you think what now
it there there's you you chase after
this thing that you can never actually
hold on to
and i think you know uh one of the
things that's greatly benefited me in
life is skateboarding because i've
always known that i've always known
there is no such thing as more there's
just doing that's why i like making
movies over making theater i used to do
a lot of theater and it was lost after
the show was done there was no record of
it and i forgot how i felt when i was
doing it but man when you record it on a
camera it's there forever but it's just
the feeling it's the feeling in the
moment because we film all the tricks
that we do
when you're done you kind of uh it is
yeah
i've done that you don't get the same
dopamine hit from doing the same thing
as you did the first time you finally
got it we uh i mean we would turn it
into profiles where like we uh i would
plan out sections like 20 30 tricks out
at different spots that i knew all of
them so you have a list of stuff to go
down to and then you get an editing what
song are you going to use i would plan
stuff out i would timeline it so i knew
this trick will be in slow motion here
because this part of the song here uh
and that is part of a longer more
artistic process but that's a beautiful
thing that does work in a longer term
sense than something that's more
immediate so it takes an immediate
activity but makes it a much longer
process so
i bring this up because think about this
if
if you're good at your at your craft
and skateboarding is the easiest thing
for me to use uh you learn how to
kickflip it's a basic trick you you
smack the board down jump in the air the
board flips under your feet you land it
you feel really really good you finally
did it but eventually it's second nature
you can just do it yeah you you feel
good sometimes you know landing a really
great kick flip i've been doing kick
flips for two and a half decades it does
not feel the exact same i remember the
first heel flip ever landed it was just
it was so i i fought for it and after a
couple weeks i was getting them perfect
and i'm like this is amazing you know i
earned this and every new trick i
learned was a struggle and a battle and
i had to figure it out and it's still
still true to this day when i skate or
blade but imagine you're in the
metaverse
that's gone yep you will just literally
click and you've got it nothing tactile
about it imagine how insane you'll go
chasing after a dragon when you're when
you're one thousand times faster at
reaching these milestones your brain's
gonna fly exactly you're gonna you're
gonna go into people are going to go
insane
clinically and like schizophrenic
psychosis
i think you will be surprised that's the
mental health crisis i had the intuition
toward 10 years ago
when they go in i mean imagine how
you're going to struggle
when people live in the metaverse
you know they'll start to come out
eventually in in a couple decades there
will be a dude wearing wearing a corn
costume juggling corn as he rides a corn
unicycle and you're like
what is this and in his personal
metaverse he has constantly chased after
something that's evolved into some weird
corn reality and it seems ridiculous
because you're like how could someone go
from a regular person to being you know
this like corn juggling corn suit guy
because in the metaverse there the the
the distance between dopamine hits is
microscopic compared to the real world
and it can you can reach infinite levels
of
cr pushing your brain into crazy
places
it'll it'll disconnect you from reality
really fast i mean i already they
believe i think that i think
a lot of these technocrats that sit
above our society right now
really believe that if they push the
human first of all they have a
hyper-inflated sense of their own
cognitive ability i believe and they
believe that if they push the human uh
mind to that point that there's some
evolution on the other side that's going
to be
you know a paradise of sorts um and i
it's just naive it's naive it's reckless
you know it's it's at least at minimum
it's not even reckless it could be
malicious too and it's like you will end
up losing it because like i've done like
you talk mental health i've done i had a
whole series of videos where i would do
uh skating segments one minute a day of
different tricks and i would do a
voiceover segment where i would talk
about what i was going through either to
film those tricks or what i was going
through that day and one of the segments
that would continually reoccur is days
where i got stuck on my phone and i get
doom scrolling through whether it's
twitter or or tick tock or facebook or
instagram thank god most of those are
going all over this instagram now like
and i would say i was like i have to get
out of the house i have to go into the
physical world and go do something that
requires tactile function yeah and and
then i would be like i would feel 10 000
times better in a way that no drug could
have ever done all just by going outside
and feeling my physical you know being
in the world i just want to let
everybody know that um almost every day
i go out and tear up some grass with my
hand
and then feed it to the chickens
so it's like people tweeted me like
touch grass tim it's like yo i have
chickens you can hear me yelling on our
chicken city stream i'm like chickens
but it's back to that physical world
keeping yourself anchored in that
physical world i mean i just like
yelling at chickens i think i think the
truth not like me yelling but just like
you know like getting their attention
and waving at him or something
andrew huberman was saying every human
should look outside for 15 minutes a day
um into the into the horizon it's just
something that fixes he's a
neuroscientist and he says it's really
the things that solve my anxiety i'm
just going to say
as a prescription of people who are
dealing with that radical anxiety and
depression the things that helped me
resolve my anxiety
were truth and gratitude
yeah i think i think we're first there's
an attack on truth
universal truth the logos like i said
but also gratitude solves a lot of these
things
right well like i
my concept of getting to the round of 32
and playing the anthony davis and
kentucky and losing but playing a good
game and they go on to win and i could
think back and go well uh what do i need
but there's a there's a there's a moment
in there in that whole you know paradigm
of thought where you could go man i'm
grateful for the opportunity to even
have done that i played in front of 16
000 people a million people on
television i played well my team
i'm grateful first gratitude first and
then the pursuit of other things is a
good model it's the same like i said
like before i came to work here i was
working at a small apartment complex i
didn't i couldn't drive didn't have any
way of getting around i just skated
every day and worked and just being
sober just knowing that uh what i i
should surely be dead by now that
there's no reason for me to be here if
you know for 99 people had done the
things i'd done wouldn't have made it
out alive i got lucky and i was blessed
to do that and have just infinite
gratitude for the fact that i was
walking and alive and healthy and a lot
of people can't seem to manage to find
that when they're you know you have to
look not just where you're going but
where you came from and if where you
came from with something so deep
debilitatingly awful that you need to
look at where you are now you you choose
to be happy yeah
some people some people don't i'm not
saying you know depression and mental
illness don't exist definitely not i'm
saying for a lot of people i hear these
stories
and they just talk about how their
life's so miserable and i'm just like
when you wake up you really it's within
you to be grateful and happy and to look
for the you know look for the good or
look for the bad and more particularly
it's up to you to choose what food you
put in your stomach because that's going
to drastically alter your state that's
true that's one of the first things i
always i just want to point out man like
when we order a bunch of pizza and then
i just eat several slices you feel like
[ __ ] yeah
when i eat like simple enough huh what
food do you put in your body and it
really really matters you know i guess
it doesn't matter when you're younger
you don't care but today we had i had
lettuce wraps i think it does matter and
i feel fantastic i bet if a lot of young
people had really healthy diets they
wouldn't be as crazy check this out we
had we did ground beef peppers onions
cheese and when i was walking out to
throw grass the chickens we have wild
chives growing because they just they
they sprout up all over the place just
grabbed a whole bunch of them rinsed
would you have where's this at you
didn't offer me any
it was before you got here oh okay
there's some leftover i know we're gonna
go find it there might be yeah yeah you
want it i definitely do the way you made
it sound
it's good yeah we just you just take
some of the mixture you put on some
lettuce and then we have i've ordered
some truffle mayo it's you know it's so
good and uh i feel i feel fantastic
we got to go to super chats though if
you haven't already smash that like
button support the show head over to
timcast.com and become a member if you
want to support us directly and uh share
the show whenever you can it's it really
really does help
let's uh let's grab some of these here
super chats what do we got here
nobody special says tim what did you
think of the batman deleted joker scene
i thought wow that movie would have been
could have actually been worse yikes
do you guys see that uh yeah
uh the scene the scene is beautifully
shot absolutely fantastic shot
beautifully uh i don't really like barry
cogan as joker i don't i think they
should leave the joker off the
off the off the ballot for at least uh
five movies they don't need they don't
need to keep going back to that
character they have no idea what they're
doing with these movies and i'm like
please like they're just beating batman
to death and i'm like stop just stop
there's so much good writing in the
batman comics
and they just keep just pulverizing it's
like yeah they did such a good job they
just can't stop
and they keep overusing batman anyways i
think he's overused totally six
63 of dc comics are all you know almost
ever dc like survives on bat family
sales so iron man too man can i can i
just throw in that i really would
appreciate if they redid the green
lantern and made a decent movie yes yeah
jon stewart green lantern that that
original ryan reynold and i like ryan
reynolds but that ryan reynolds green
lantern movie was
it was
he doesn't like that movie either he did
not know he died i bet he doesn't yeah
that was completely absurd have you seen
uh the atom project no it's uh on
netflix i thought it was good i'm not i
don't think it was lord of the rings or
anything you know i give it a c plus b
minus we reviewed i loved it i was like
to me it's one of those things where i
just movies today are so i'm so hyper
focused on not hating the agenda that
gets driven into most of these films
that when i just get like a general
family film with nothing offensive label
as far as like agenda being just shoved
into it i'm like that was fantastic so
like 10 years ago it would have been
like a b minus or a c plus i'm like a
minus yeah that was fantastic yeah this
is a really good super chat actually
rylo says um
if katanji brown jackson can't define
woman how can she define the 19th
amendment
the reason why that's a really good
question is the 19th amendment um
affirms a woman's right to vote
but if a trans woman is a woman then
women already had the right to vote
would you lose the right to vote if you
transitioned you wouldn't
i think that really interesting we need
to make trans women a word and trans man
or trans men a word i guess because it's
they're just different things than man
and woman trans men trans they're just
different things the different different
definitions
let's go with it
so it says okay it says the right of
citizens of the united states to vote
shall not be denied or bridged by the
united states or by any state on account
of sex
that's very interesting that means so
the the the amendment doesn't actually
say man or woman which would mean that
based on today's logic women always had
the right to vote which means that the
entire suffrage movement
where the neo-liberal women went to
black women and said hey the black man
got the right to vote before you did
let's go after him that goes out the
window the suffrage movement is they
don't talk about that
they don't want you to know about that
oh that that the white woman went that
black man got the right to vote before i
did that racism played a big role in the
suffrage movement yeah i mean look i
think women should have the right to
vote absolutely everybody should but
definitely
and planned parenthood racism played a
huge role in the formation of planned
parenthood
you know what man it's funny that they
say the truth is right wing or i'm sorry
they're basically they're effectively
saying it they'll call you a liar
they'll say your right wing but if you
tell the truth they'll call you right
when they'll call you conservative even
if you're not
yeah i don't know welcome to the modern
era i don't even know where this the
political political spectrum's all over
the place now you know that i mean
there's plenty of people who are
traditionally liberal who have just been
pushed over to the right wing by by
default by a far left manic or the right
wing has been pulled to encompass people
who are liberal yeah i would have been
considered a disaffected liberal who
became more libertarian at least more
like uh you know minimize the state
uh the you know just by being pulled
this way through the just how far left
the rest of the agenda is that uh i've
just been moved that way and then since
then have grown and learned and changed
my positions in certain areas but
definitely would have never been
considered right-wing or republican or
conservative just not
i'm they're calling me the alt right now
all right i'm all right no no but uh uh
you know my favorite is only white
people can be racist but candace owens
is a white supremacist yes
it's just
whatever i love that one that's right
glyph zero says here's to some
conditioner for ian should cover
inflation on it for a week thank you
i use a conditioner that is for infants
by the way i treat my hair nice shampoo
all right david
what does it say david c kronk senior i
find it interesting that the united
states has placed economic sanctions on
russia during this invasion that we
never placed on hitler during world war
ii we are forcing our own economic
demise i'd like to point out that joe
biden said we were going to disseminate
food shortages yeah
and then he also said the food shortages
are going to be the result of sanctions
and he's the one who pushed these
sanctions so it's kind of like maybe he
was telling the truth about
disseminating food shortages yep yeah
maybe it's american policy it's leading
to it
all right mickey stone says
u.s generals are negotiating with
chinese officials trading taiwan for
russia in australia right now i have a
reliable friend in the adf
that is a bold claim
maybe we'll see something about that but
uh i don't know man i'm i am skeptical
on those internet claims without
evidence that'd be crazy though
considering that joe biden's talking
about ramping up production chip
production in the us the u.s seems to be
ready to lose taiwan
long overdue
one of the things he's getting right
yeah yeah in theory absolutely yeah good
credit requests to do you know raymond g
stanley jr says all roads seem to lead
to white liberal women yep it's suburban
white women who voted for joe biden
you know they were the big swing
there was a sign in my neighborhood in
when i was still living in in west saint
paul that said uh vote for kamala harris
dot dot dot and joe biden
interesting so they weren't even voting
for him then they were voting for her
for vice president and then i guess
we'll take joe as president just because
howard says in a big super chat thanks
very much respect you're getting closer
guy a good job
is that reference anybody no nothing
closer guy a good job getting it i'm
assuming he means me
let's find out nsx says this man talks
like a stoic paladin i can't vote
australian but you have my prayers very
cool thank you are you familiar with the
paladin no from dungeons and dragons
of god yeah he uses divine energy
thank you i appreciate that thank you
you have an aura of healing it's good
i've never been called that usually
called pretty radical maybe you guys
calm me down i appreciate you guys
allowed me to be comfortable to have a
nice calm conversation i get theatrical
all right dragon lady says tim i live in
toledo area where the floyd mural was it
was not partly cloudy that day rained
off and on all day massive storm rolled
in at the time of the lightning strike
sky was dark pouring rain high winds
much lightening i watched it fantastic
storm
interesting
i'm still wondering how the roof wasn't
damaged and only george floyd was was
blown off the side of the building
god's wrath
metal in the paint that's mine you know
what it is the whole wall was painted
just whatever they used on his face was
like a special paint or something yeah i
want to say something real quick about
george floyd okay
this guy doesn't to say that the state
has gone too far that we always have to
be mindful of the authority and scope of
governance as citizens is not the same
to enshrine him as a hero although i
know that some people may think he's a
hero um and looking at the situation
where he was involved in the home
invasion and put the gun to a pregnant
woman's stomach which i i don't know if
that's a true story
was it i thought that was debunked that
uh i could i could be wrong and that
somebody would have maybe it was i
thought that the at least the part about
him holding the gun to a pregnant
woman's belly i heard that that was
deborah i'm just saying that
what i want people on both sides to do
is separate
am i a roman citizen do you have the
right to bind and beat a roman citizen
who has not been convicted of a crime
and george floyd regardless of who he
was in his life
has a right to have a trial
um and he had a family he has a humanity
regardless of what he had done so agreed
yeah yeah uh
this is why i'm actually a fan of bail
reform
i think there's problems with it you see
what happens in new york when repeat
offenders just keep getting let go and
crimes keep happening so there's gotta
be a way to stop that for sure but i
don't like the idea that you could be
poor
get accused of a crime let alone you
know not even proven have done anything
wrong and they can say we can lock you
up for an extended period of time that
means you're going to lose your job
you'll probably get evicted people will
wonder where you went it'll be hard to
communicate i'm like no no
i actually i think about kyle
rittenhouse for example what do you
spend almost three months in jail only
only for the state to finally come out
tyranny what right what every there's
video evidence it was clear cut that
should have he should have been in and
out of court the cops should have looked
at that the d.a should have been like
but instead because of politics they
were like let's let's lock them up for a
while d.a is in on it kyle rittenhouse
if he was going to be locked up by the
state should have been given a
let's just say four star hotel not five
star but you should you should have a
nice accommodation because you're not
convicted of any crime if the state
wants to hold you you should be held in
complete median middle class standards
instead they put you in jail with
everybody else you lose your job now you
got an internet you should be allowed to
use the phone at your own discretion
internet access you've done no wrong why
can't you communicate at least
if they've not i understand saying look
we we have reason to believe you
committed a crime so we're gonna be
holding you
but because you have because we don't
want you to commit another crime or hurt
somebody but there's no reason you can't
talk to your family or get access to the
internet right no no i i'm not a fan of
locking people up uh because what
happens is a lot of cops use the process
as the punishment they say i know that i
can get you two days in jail if i arrest
you right now for any reason i make up
or say yeah so in new york you have cops
uh they've they often do this they'll
arrest someone because it's like it's
easier just to deal with arresting a
protester otherwise
center the station let them stew over
the weekend they'll get out charge will
be dropped but it took care of the
problem in the short term i think that's
terrible we shouldn't the state should
not be allowed to do this but hey look
new york is run by democrats who appoint
democrat cops who do these things to
themselves and i don't live there
anymore for that reason and it's not
just the democrat that that's a that's a
bipartisan problem i think definitely
the the the uh prison system and the
criminal justice system but the prison
system primarily is the lowest rung of
the military-industrial complex law
enforcement and police are the second
lowest rung and it goes up to
geopolitical uh warfare and conflict
after that and when we were downstairs
talking we the first thing i mentioned
you guys like and the minneapolis police
department has always been known as
being extremely corrupt and we knew that
from the beginning that that was always
a problem there's a cultural consensus
for people who live in the in minnesota
about the police department there yeah
absolutely all right jay says i agree
with ian despair is strong right now
while i don't have a path i am still
walking hope is never dead
keep walking um
i think
fixing your diet up is a big key of of
this path
you'll be okay i like this comment mike
s says it is a travesty that this man is
not a leader in this world we need to
replace the spineless cowards in the
establishment with people like this
thank you sir for running and good luck
thank you i would like to say
he is a leader in this world you don't
got to be in politics to be a leader
but you know having political power
would be great if you had good leaders
yeah there's been there's been a
dereliction of duty from people who are
capable let's say of being
transformative leaders in the political
in the political uh realm
um and look you know i'm still 30 years
old i'm in the middle of a pro-mixed
martial arts career my debut was on
december 10th i lost a three-round
decision yeah yeah i fought on lfa on
the fight pass so i've transitioned to
pro-mix martial arts and i can i plan to
continue to keep fighting but um
none of our personal pursuits right now
in this time of crisis should should uh
have us abnegate our duty to society and
that that is the crooks i believe of the
the fruit of an idea like nationalism
puts constraints on the individual's
ambitions and it anchors us in in
charity in a christian way and says the
order of charity is local do you have a
podcast right now
no i don't that would be good thank you
so when you're talking about the order
of charity being local meaning that you
want people to help out within their own
community and that's more important than
people who start to rely on the state
because they don't they feel like
they're not connected to a community no
yes that too but i mean that the order
of charity and
greco-judeo-christian values is my fir
myself first
then my family
and then my immediate community what the
neoliberal globalist movement is try to
reorder the chariot and say send money
for mosquito nets in africa for malaria
and it's just so disconnected um again
it it it it makes it so people aren't
anchored in in the in the reality and
facts and truth in the in their
immediate life
it's a trick it's a it's a three-car
monty just like those people who like i
was like i wish i could pay more taxes
like i would pay more i don't mind
paying taxes at the pump if it means
that we help the ukraine yeah that's
it's just it's actually offensive and
you can pay more taxes you i don't think
the irs can stop you from paying more
right it's like the white woman from the
gq uh this is the pro the perfect motif
of the white the crisis in white liberal
women
is the woman who
interviewed jordan peterson from the gq
magazine yeah kathy yeah yeah and he is
awful and he backs her into a corner and
she tells us exactly what's wrong with
the liberal ideology he says if you're
so privileged and there's so many people
who could use who could benefit from
what you have why don't you give up your
job and she just sits back and goes no
i'm not going to do that that's helen
lewis is her name
all right randy devel says get him on
joe rogan great podcast we need more
more men like this republicans and
democrats keep doing what you're doing
proud tim cast member
uh and and yes and also lily tang
williams but uh that's just
that only happens if joe knows who they
are because i certainly don't hit him up
and be like you know alex alex jones
said the same thing when i was on his
podcast and shout out to joe rogan i
think what he's done is is incredible he
stood in the breach too
and uh yeah i'm a huge fan i saw you
first on on on rogan uh and then and
then i started watching your stuff so
yeah shout out to joe rogan he's a good
dude man that's my
eternally yes sir
that's my n word i don't want to get you
guys the episode brought down but i love
that out of sonya uh sound bite that's
my n-word i love that
all right let's see chris does stuff
says tim have you had an out-of-body
experience no
have you ian
no i've had lucid dreams where i felt
where i was like flying around i'm
flying and then all of a sudden i'm
flying and stuff like that almo i would
say
there came a point in my life where uh
basically every single dream i have is
lucid
oh that's awesome yeah what about you
guys have you had out about experience
my first panic attack my first panic
attack came from smoking marijuana
um and i just had it was a massive panic
attack and i i just was watching myself
walk around i thought i was gonna die
and you know somehow i was able to call
my my grandfather came i didn't want to
call my mom because where i'm from
your mom's beating you for sure grandpa
was a little bit more meaningful so i
called him but i don't even remember how
i was able to manage that because i was
so disordered um and i was like watching
myself walk around so yeah anxiety
attacks often feel like that yeah so for
lucid dreaming just to clarify uh
there's techniques you can do
so there's something i think it's called
like walking into a dream or something
like that it's where you basically just
use your imagination as you start to
fall asleep and then basically trigger
what the dream is or something like that
there's also other things you you're
supposed to do you keep keep a dream
journal you wear something consistently
uh on your wrist or whatever that you
check that way when you're in a dream it
doesn't behave a certain way you
instantly get snapped out of you you
instantly become lucid there's a bunch
of things that i've done
just like a long time ago that became
second nature and now it's like i'll
fall asleep
and then all of a sudden i'll be like oh
i'm dreaming i was having a lucid dream
and i
knew i was awake but i was asleep
dreaming on a pirate ship and i i
started to breathe out too much and the
dream started to shake like inception
like the entire reality started rip
apart i was like oh it's an oxygenation
issue or like a carbon dioxide issue
there's something about the breathing
yeah we need to master our dream master
in here
all right
dawn's herald says in regard to the
temptation of neuralink quote the devil
doesn't come dressed in a red cape and
pointy horns he comes as everything
you've ever wished for that's my thought
boom yeah dude life you need
in the matrix i said this humans need
struggle
how boring is it if you just
accomplished everything instantly
overnight you'd not be happy you
wouldn't feel nothing so and so the
rightful criticism of our system and
establishment isn't that they've set up
a society where people have to struggle
in order to find meaning it's that
they've been predatory and corrupt and
dishonest in how they've set the playing
field and presented it as one that's
fair and honest when really it's overtly
corrupt so that's my take on it
all right darius harvey he just says
good show thanks for the super chat
let's see um
carpe diem dm says hats off to lauren
southern for getting a ban on twitch by
replaying a debate she had with destiny
wait really that happened destiny's
banned wow
wow oh my gosh no no twitch bands are
like temporary everyone's always like
you got banned you have been solidly
banned i think
he got banned before of the cow written
house thing and then they let him back
on
there was a good super chat i wanted to
read oh here we go florida man says tim
said he doesn't fear losing everything
but you have created so many meaningful
connections that even if you lost
everything you would have a social
safety net i think that means you've
made it i can certainly understand and
respect that but i would just point out
the reason why i'm never really scared
of losing everything is because i have
witnessed people make 200 a day sleeping
literally going down on chicago and
going to sleep and then people just i
remember uh yeah just the guy i knew
this guy woke up in a folger's can full
of cash
and he was like yeah i make about 200 a
day and then he bought heroin with it it
was messed up
about 700 dollars a day and and and
well i don't think he sleeps but he
would just sleep it's the craziest thing
so he would do whatever his thing was
then and then he would go to bed at like
nine in the morning on the corner of
somewhere in downtown chicago and then
he'd wake up after a few hours with a
can just full of money that's all that's
50 200 a month
a lot of money well i don't know if he's
doing seven days a week but yeah he said
so when i saw him he had he had 184
something in a folger's can just full of
change and bills and he brought it into
he walked into the bank and he poured
into their sorting machine and then he
deposited it and he was like yeah and
then i was like man you're making a lot
of money goes yeah but i do a lot of
heroin so like yeah and i was like dude
that sucks yep and that's why he's
sleeping outside because it's but i was
like have you thought about getting
clean and getting a job and he's like i
make too much money
so my point with that is i have seen
american
you know
compassion and it is it is it is there
there is copious amounts of it people
will just give you money i tell people
all the time you stand in a street
corner and say the word cheeseburger and
nothing else
eventually someone will either hand you
cash or a cheeseburger i'm not even
kidding like someone will walk into
mcdonald's and grab one and walk out
back here you go buddy because it's like
it's a dollar or two right yeah because
people in america really are they they
they're really nice at least in the real
world the people in america on twitter
just want to emotionally destroy you for
some reason i don't know why my aunt
that i grew up who's like a second
mother to me every time she sees
somebody who even looks remotely
homeless
uh she she looks for cash in her car and
she gives it to him i usually give him
high fives to like shake their hand and
they're they're so much happier than
when i hand them money like eye contact
like i love you man weird how that works
uh i i'm one of those i give a lot like
i would rather give money to somebody on
the corner yeah rather because if you
were to give to charity you have to do
your do you do your due diligence you
have to look at how much of this is
actually going to the cause in question
how much of it is going to
administrative fees and stuff like that
i'm much more likely to just want to
give it to the guy who's like this guy's
out on the court we go to the a walmart
over here all the time and there's this
one place where there's always people
there and i if i have it i will give it
to them because like at least i know
that it's going to this person and
whatever he chooses to spend that on not
my choice but i make that choice for
that trend the transactional nature of
that relationship and i'm okay with that
at least as far as uh that form of
charity i like
i i'm wary of giving cash to random
people holding signs because i i i knew
people growing up it's called flying
signs and so they would be like hey did
you want to go fly signs and it's like
literally people with apartments oh it's
like a scam yeah i guess you call it a
scam it's like a job just not a they
call it flying science
you know the most powerful sign i've
ever seen in my life was i've seen a lot
of signs what you so so first let me
just give you give you some backstory
you've seen the signs where like a guy
says let's be honest i'm gonna buy beer
and the idea is to be funny and then
it's like ah it's relatable some people
do the normal signs like you know i'm
homeless and i'm working really hard and
i could use support i saw one guy in
chicago with his head down and his sign
said i have nothing please understand
and i almost started crying when i saw
that sign dude because he didn't ask me
for anything
so i was like i'm gonna give this guy
whatever i can
but uh uh
you know i i i'll i'll give to people
you know but when i do give to somebody
who's just flying a sign i'll be like
the money i'm giving you is for you to
do whatever you want with have a good
day man like it's literally the ideas
you you might just take the cash because
you make a lot of money do this you're
not homeless i don't care whatever but i
much prefer to just do massive tips at
restaurants
cause then you've got someone
they're working a job
probably not the greatest job in the
world you got to deal with crappy
customers i always like in whatever
capacity i can just do a massive tip
because then it's like you're being
rewarded for the work you're doing right
now
a lesson i learned from my mom if i
didn't have a job she wouldn't help me
out financially at all but if i got a
job she'd be like okay i'll give you
i'll help you out with your rent if you
can't afford it if you have a job yeah
that's worthwhile my dad told me that
what he would do is like he would go out
and he'd see people with vietnam veteran
signs like i'm a vietnam vet and he
would quiz them on like what rifle did
you carry because he wouldn't give it to
them unless he
they for sure served in vietnam i
thought that was very uh very clever of
him to at least keep them honest in that
way the hardest thing i think for us to
decide going forward as a society is
what to do with the least amongst us
what's what's reasonable to do and it's
not an easy it's not going to be easy
solution and anybody who says that they
have some some fail-safe solution at how
to approach that they're just kind of
being dishonest you know it's it's gonna
it's a hard one because because
especially if
i know how close i was
in your people are hitting the chat and
i appreciate their compliments but
they also got to realize that i'm a
testament i was this close i could have
easily been dead or overdosed or in the
gutter from being addicted to benzos and
i got them prescribed by a doctor so
imagine how many people are coming by
this circumstance in in ways that aren't
malicious or you know you know what else
i want to mention seriously
what about the other direction
i want people to hear this you told a
story about how you stood up for what
you believed in and you refused to back
down
you could you could have been a
superstar but you decided that there
were certain things that were more
important
so now you're you're still fighting
you're still leading you're still you're
still you're fighting now literally
fighting literally yeah but you're
you're doing your thing you're always
doing you know what i mean there are a
lot of people that i i'm willing to bet
a lot of people told you to shut up and
dribble oh the entire liberal
establishment that's that's the ironic
part yeah from from from root to branch
the entire liberal establishment said
you're too smart for your own good if
you just play if you just play you'll
have more leverage
to get them to do what what they should
do
um and yeah i mean it's i
i just gave him the finger and said you
know let's play the long game let's play
the long game in my life and let's play
it in the eternal and see who wins i
think you're doing well man did you um
have a moment like a flexing moment
where your mental health like just
something changed yeah it was telling it
was telling the truth and and having
gratitude
um but but
you found the right path
but but it started early right the only
the only snag i had in there is that i
was still tied to my material dreams and
that i thought i could salvage something
with the nba and have that career but
but i got to a point where i realized
that we are
we are antithetical
our energy our
i don't say energy at a fake walkway i
mean like the momentum of where we're
headed is antithetical but the real
turning point for me was a 14 year old
when i first started talking about
anxiety in the public square when this
whole nba thing broke out a 14 year old
girl who i thought was said she was a 14
year old girl out of new jersey
um sent me a message on twitter and said
that she was a cutter
that she had cut herself
and that that me talking about mental
health in the public square
gave her hope
and i took that to a conversation with
david stern
and said these are the people that you
are obligated to
the these are the people that you're
obligated to spearhead this movement for
and be honest
and he scoffed at it and from there we
were mortal enemies me as a righteous
and divine warrior for god and the
christian christian faith that i serve
and him as a as a uh
you know a chameleonic globalist
authoritarian elite and we're and we're
at odds so yeah the war is on right on
man all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends that's the most powerful way to
help because if everybody shared the
show we'd be bigger than cnn overnight
truth be told i think in many ways we
are bigger than them but they have a
massive youtube channel so let's let's
get out there and um if you guys want to
support us that grassroots marketing is
powerfully effective you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
at tim cast royce do you want to shout
anything out
um royce white dot us that's our
campaign website you can also follow me
on getter and sub stack um i appreciate
it man thanks for having me on god speed
absolutely thank you
uh guys you can follow me at brett
dasvik on instagram but also pop culture
crisis on youtube uh if you go to the
youtube channel we cut up all the
segments in the videos i didn't have as
much to say tonight but i promise i have
a great amount to say on just about
everything we talk about there uh
probably more than most people would
expect uh and then if you do that uh in
the description box of any of those
youtube videos takes you to the spotify
playlist that has all the episodes start
to finish it's the best way to watch the
show uh me miracle and we're gonna have
some more changes and some different
things coming to the show in the near
future sweet i wanted to make sure you
you're on twitter too
uh yeah twitter but don't highway
underscore where to score 30. that's
what i tweeted out i wanna make sure
it's you it's a graveyard dude maybe you
guys got more juice than me i've been
shadow band for for for years
tonight thank you thank you hey brett
good to see you again man royce amazing
to meet you thank you brother thank you
guys i can't tell look the establishment
told me face to face
if you don't do what we say there's no
chance that you'll have a voice and
you'll be able to help people and you
guys doing stuff like this and giving me
a platform
uh allows me allows me to do what i want
to do and and proves them wrong so thank
you i really appreciate it brother i
will see you guys next wednesday i'll be
out of town on a little adventure and
i'll let you know how that goes alrighty
yes thank you very much for coming
tonight royce i hope that more people
will follow you and learn more about you
your fighting career your basketball
playing career and that guardian article
that came out that was actually pretty
good about you i recommend people go
check that out for sure kill a
background on rice you guys may follow
me on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchlids we will see all of you
guys well actually you can go right now
to youtube.com chicken city if you want
to see some sleek sleeping chickens and
a bunch of new babies just hatched and
uh we have the vlog going the vlog is
back up at youtube.comcastcastle
so check that out and other than that
we'll see you all on monday thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you